richard dolan is one of the world's most
lauded ufo researchers and historians
his most recent book the alien agendas
is a taxonomy of alien beings based on
eyewitness testimonial behavioral and
visual characteristics for those new to
this channel my name is kurt jaimungle
i'm a filmmaker with a background in
mathematical physics dedicated to the
explication of what are called theories
of everything from a theoretical physics
perspective as well as the possible
connection consciousness has to the
fundamental laws of the universe
provided these laws exist at all and are
knowable to us if you're interested in
getting acquainted with this channel or
getting someone else up to speed there's
a top 10 list in the description that
focuses on theoretical physics
psychology mathematics philosophy and so
on but if you're more interested in the
ufo phenomenon then there's a ufo
playlist in the description as well
where we talk to people like luis
elisondo jeremy corbell jacques valet
kevin knuth as well as some of the more
academic luminaries such as noam chomsky
avi loeb even stephen wolfram on the
topic of alien life most of the time
when i'm interviewing someone regarding
my bailiwick of theoretical physics
mathematics consciousness and so on it
involves a level of preparation that's
unduly high but that's not the case when
it comes to this ufo topic for a few
reasons number one my time is already
stretched extremely thin but that could
be said about anyone number two luckily
this podcast is getting to the point
where i can interview people who are at
the top of their given field which means
instead of me learning about this ufo
phenomenon or particular ufo case from a
third party i can go straight to the
source number three it gives the
opportunity for those who are ufologists
maybe yourself those in the community
who are extremely well acquainted to ask
questions directly to these kanye
shentis since this is an ama and ask me
anything in some ways it has to be
because my questions would be extremely
naive okay and then number four as you
know much of the scientific community is
extremely scornful about the topic of
ufos relegating it to pseudoscience or
the confabulation of those with marginal
intelligence who precipitately jump to
conclusions i myself don't hold this
view and in fact think that innovation
will almost necessarily come from the
fringes at least i'm making my bet on
that the audience of this podcast tend
to be extremely intelligent comprising
even professors of mathematics physics
even computer science and they they feel
uh or at least they've told me that they
feel a kinship toward me
particularly because i'm trained
classically in those domains many of
them have messaged me reached out
privately and sometimes even publicly in
the comment section and told me that my
coverage on this topic has swayed them
from a position of
extreme skepticism to a position where
it's like i don't know what the heck is
happening at all and this is in
particular because i'm not a member of
the ufo community i'm no ufologist and
this paradoxically serves to legitimate
the study of these transpirations in its
own minor way with some small subset of
the scientifically minded audience
namely that of the theories of
everything podcast audience thus if my
questions ever seem sophomoric or
simplistic it's because i'm sophomoric
and simplistic at least with respect to
this subject it's a double-edged sword
if you'd like to hear more conversations
like this for example george knapp or
christopher melon or perhaps both of
them on at the same time then please do
consider going to patreon.com
kurt jymungal and supporting it may
sound silly but literally every dollar
helps as this is what i do full time
i've also recently opened up a crypto
address and there's a paypal address as
well in case any of those platforms are
more up your alley the plan is to have
more conversations like this with ever
increasing quality approximately once a
week there are a couple sponsors of
today's podcast algo is an end-to-end
supply chain optimization software
company with software that helps
business users optimize sales and
operations planning to avoid stockouts
reduce returns and inventory write-downs
while reducing inventory investment it's
a supply chain ai that drives smart roi
headed by a bright individual by the
name of amjad hussein who has been a
huge supporter of this podcast from its
early days the second sponsor is
brilliant brilliant illuminates the soul
of mathematics science and engineering
with bite-sized interactive learning
experiences brilliance courses explore
the laws that shape our world elevating
math and science from something to be
feared to a delightful experience of
guided discovery more on them later
thank you and enjoy
okay if anyone can see this
type the word
piccolo
piccolo piccolo
or gohan
hold on hold on it may not work let me
double check i just just for my
microphone won't last time you hear that
when i tap this yep yep yep it's the
correct microphone i'm going to be
taking audience live questions live
audience questions so in the chat
make sure when you're asking a question
you at me because then i could see it
more clearly
firstly you said around 1962 there was
an explosion of nuclear bombs off the
coast of hawaii
and i think it was 36 nuclear bombs and
there was a ufo there that got shot down
if i heard
correctly
can you explain what happened
yeah that was part of something known as
operation dominic
uh dominic is something you can find on
online you can find a wikipedia entry on
it
uh during you know that part of the cold
war we're talking late 1950s early 60s
both the united states and the soviet
union were
pretty much at their peak of nuclear
detonations
so actually from i think 1945 till the
1998 end of the 20th century
uh the world experienced i think 2050
nuclear detonations
quite amazing and
so operation dominic was one very small
sliver of that whole history
but it was a special series of um high
altitude tests
over the pacific and it's true about i
think 500 miles off the
uh west coast western tip of hawaii
is most of that
so that's all we know and we know all
about that and that took place
um
it ended
it ended actually right around the time
of the
october the
missile crisis the cuban missile crisis
of 1962 almost exactly around that time
i wrote about it in one of my books
because i spoke to retired navy man
his first name is david and i had a
series of long conversations with him
and he
told me
about his experience
as a
navy seaman aboard a vessel
that
was uh in the area
they were not doing the missile launches
but they were there and this was in
october of it was the second i think the
second last dominic uh detonation if i'm
not mistaken
and he described a fascinating and i for
me believable ufo encounter that uh his
vessel had
and i can't actually remember the name
of his vessel it's i wrote about it in
my book ufos for the 21st century mind i
could pull it out but sure it doesn't
matter yeah yeah yeah so basically what
happened is he was uh he was on a vessel
the dead nation was set to go off he
like all the other
semen on the vessel were told to go
below deck
and
an officer came down and said i want you
you you you and you up up right now
and david was one of them and they were
actually just told to stand uh i think
on the starboard side and they were
supposed to just face straight forward
not look at anything else don't look
left don't look right
and this man saw and
a ufo like zoomed by
and presumably he thought it was it went
into the ocean
he learned later he's doing crosstrain
with radar operators later that day and
he
in the scuttlebutt learned that they
were tracking
ufo they tracked ufos he said all the
time during detonations and he said
typically what would happen would be uh
bogeys would be up in the atmosphere
just before detonations and then they
would be gone
just before the detonation occurred so
they apparently were monitoring and then
got the hell out when it happened but
apparently not in this case because what
he learned from the radar operators he
said was that
uh apparently this one got hit and it
came down and it was tracked and it was
pursued by u.s navy
pickup team whatever that was and
uh he had a follow-up to that which was
some years later he did a tour of duty
at guantanamo bay in cuba in um i think
the 70s
and by chance at the bar spoke to uh
navy guy they were like trading stories
what do you got oh i got something
interesting oh yeah well i got something
even more this guy turned out to be a
diver
according to this man the first diver
down to
investigate this exact same craft from
1962.
went down below the water
uh didn't realize he was standing on the
object until he slid off of it
actually
uh peed in his suit from the nervousness
uh was able to see what he saw described
as like a honeycomb kind of semi
clear semi-opaque
with lots of little combs inside and did
he ever draw it
he did not go inside he stood outside it
but he said it was somewhat
trans somewhat transparent i suppose
what i mean is did he ever draw it like
make a sketch of it
there is
no i don't have a sketch from this man
david but uh
based on that description there was an
artist
who offered his own interpretation of it
which seemed to fit what i got when i
interviewed this man so a very large
object with a
kind of transparent honeycomb pattern
and then he apparently what this diver
believed he knew is that the team sent
down or the navy sent out another team
either a day or
more later and the object was not there
so they were not able to recover this
object this ufo
that is the story that the questioner is
asking about so
short version
m kelly wants to know what do you think
of what do you think is the most common
myth in the ufo phenomena or related to
the ufo phenomena myth it's a tough one
to know i don't know how to answer that
not sure what what uh this person is
asking particularly like the most common
untruth
right about ufos i suppose um
in your opinion
widely promulgated as being
oh like in today's culture
well i mean look you have a lot of
people in the ufo field who
talk as though they really know exactly
what these other beings are
and it happens all the time and
um i mean for my part i've studied this
for
more than 25 years now and
i can say honestly i don't i don't
pretend that i know exactly like for
sure what these other beings are i
speculated about them in my most recent
book the alien agendas but that doesn't
mean that i know i just i'm doing my
best speculative analysis but there are
definitely folks out there who
will uh
talk up a big game and they'll act as
though they know precisely the nature of
these beings
uh frequently you'll find that they are
are
some version or other of space brothers
or um you know
people here
to help us achieve the next level of our
development
so that we can join the galactic
community um in my opinion that's
probably a very widespread
i would call that a myth
i'm not saying that every alien race
that's ever visited us is necessarily
evil or out to get us or put us in a
cookbook but i would say
uh there's definitely a long history of
that type of idea and i've never found
it very persuasive
there's probably other myths i could
find time to think about it might be
even
bigger than that but
that's that's one
in the alien agendas you go through this
taxonomy of aliens of alien types or
sub-species and so on
and you also mentioned the word evil
here
to me
if they were evil they seem so
technologically advanced that they could
destroy us at any point do you think
that the evil ones have some other
agenda other than our instantaneous
destruction yeah i think well you know
i don't like i don't use the word evil
for any of these guys let's use the word
and i don't use the word good either i
mean
you know from our human instinct we're
naturally inclined to look at things as
threat or not threat
and that's how we're supposed to do it
like that's our that's our evolution
so i guess from that sense you could say
evil if they are a threat but
if there's if there's a dangerous group
here and i
i tend to think that the answer to that
is there is a dangerous group here
actually um
why haven't they destroyed us well like
why you know
how would they do that is a real good
question to ask like would they
surround us like independence day and
just fire like laser beams or like you
know the future terminator scenarios
when they
you know patrol the skies and just
destroy humanity i mean is that really
what they would want to do
what if they actually like earth what if
they think earth is a cool place and
what if they are trying to figure out a
way to inhabit earth without all those
messy humans
so if that was the case
how would they go about doing it
would they would they engage in massive
warfare like world war ii and just
destroy cities and turn them into rubble
or would they go about another method or
if and this is all if this is we don't
know i don't know the person asking the
question doesn't you don't know but if
there are other groups that are um
interested in
having other agendas maybe there are
other groups that are not
here to take us out maybe there there's
another group out there that might see
us as their property and they might want
to cultivate us the way we cultivate
farm animals i don't know so if you've
got different groups
engaged perhaps there might be a covert
measure to this whole
activity of of extraterrestrials
i mean i realize as i'm saying this to
you that this could sound just totally
far out to someone especially who hasn't
studied ufos or not looked into the
phenomenon at all they're like this is
totally nuts the thing is that
um
there's a few things that i i can say
that i know
all right
question you just asked that's
speculation and i don't know
but what i do know is that
there is a
long long
proven
history of documentary
documentary evidence i guess i would say
that doesn't hint it doesn't suggest but
it does prove
that there's a phenomenon
that exists in the skies the atmosphere
the oceans uh and on the ground of
planet earth that's not supposed to
exist and then military personnel have
engaged in this for many many years and
they in the highest level documents that
i've been able to find
you see these people scratching their
heads or being gravely concerned
about objects that don't look normal
don't behave normally
and have a very definite interest in our
nuclear technology and nuclear weapons
that's no question about it uh they are
seen around the world not just the
united states but the old soviet union
has a large large number of these
stories in these reports
so that there's something going on in
which there there is someone
here
it's not supposed to exist
with technology that's
not supposed to exist similarly
and that is a matter of great secrecy
we can call it a cover-up
what do you mean when you say not
supposed to exist
it's not supposed to exist in terms of
our current understanding of what we
think we know about the world in the
universe
you know an object is not supposed to be
able to zigzag
or instantly accelerate without making a
sound or just disappear or
you know be shaped like a flying saucer
and actually have the stability the
aerodynamic stability to be able to do
things it does like we don't we don't
have a way of explaining that we don't
have a way of explaining the so-called
tic tac ufo encounter of 2004 which has
been discussed quite a bit by navy
commander david faber
uh in which you have an object
essentially accelerating instantly to
estimate 10 000 miles per hour or more
we don't we don't know so that's not
supposed to be the case in the sense of
our physics we don't we don't have a
good explanation for how to do that and
those types of reports by the way
reliable reports military reports with
instrumentation they go back to the
1940s i myself found um a report in the
canadian archives
dating from going describing an event
from 1936 in the northwest territories
of tic tac toy ufo with instant
acceleration and thousands of miles per
hour
so there's enough of these
that that's those are real head
scratchers in terms of how do you
explain those things in terms of
aerodynamics and and aviation history
and all of that like we don't we don't
have
a way to
explain those at all
so that's what i mean and then on top of
that there are enough reports
by
people that i personally have considered
credible
who have described encounters with like
what you can only call alien beings
i'm not saying every
description of an encounter with an
alien being is oh yeah absolutely i
believe it no i don't but i believe some
of them i believe enough of them to
think that there are alien beings that
are here so i think that's connected to
the ufo phenomenon
absolutely and you were talking before
air off air about my interest which is
primarily physics related and
consciousness related and these crafts
seem to
at least ostensibly break the laws of
physics that's extremely interesting to
me you also mentioned the ocean okay now
this question comes from amjad hussein
do you know of any evidence that
suggests ufos have a base underwater
yes
well let's let's just say i would i
would describe that as um
circumstantial indications
all right so um
maybe that's a better way to put it
there's a long history of ocean-based
and water-based ufo encounters
it's quite fascinating i mean to the
extent that those objects have their own
acronym uso which is unidentified
submersible objects instead of ufos
so there's enough of those there's a
couple of good books i have one lying
around here somewhere called invisible
residence by ivan t sanderson from over
50 years ago it's a very good book uh he
was a good writer and
and there's been other
compilations of water-based ufo
encounters most recently a website
called waterufo.net i believe by the
late carl find
it's a very good site
there's a number of
um
ufo sightings or uso sightings of
objects
going into and exiting large bodies of
water
in fact recently you have louise
elizondo formerly of ttsa to the stars
academy
lou of course is a counterintelligence
officer
department of defense for many years
and he talks about transmedium objects
when he ran the atip program back in the
early 2000s in other words a transmedium
object is an object that can
go from water to air or air to water in
other words different mediums
so with all of that i think you know
when you consider the earth is 75
covered by water
uh
it actually makes perfect sense to me we
have we have technology we've had for 50
years or more that can go deep deep
underground and that includes under the
ocean floor because the technology is
the same so
i know
you know of research going back to the
1960s in which the united states navy
was looking into technology to go deep
underground under the ocean floors they
were actively exploring this
now did they well we don't have answers
to that all we know is that they had
plans the technology was not out of the
question for them the money was not out
of the question for them either
the motivation was certainly there my
guess is they probably did it
if if our navy had the ability to go
under the ocean in other words and then
you know you ask yourself well how could
you have a viable base down there you
still have to have oxygen and energy but
that's actually not that difficult
you know they hydrolysis uh out of the
ocean you just extract the oxygen from
the
ocean we know how to do that that's how
nuclear submarines can stay under
submerged for months and months at a
time
they're taking oxygen out of the water
so we knew how to do that and all you
need is some geothermal or maybe small
nuclear generator down there and you
could have the lights on and play
ping-pong all day long under the ocean
floor
as long as the geology is good
so i think i think the logic for a
non-human species that wants to be here
quietly
sure
ocean-based ufo makes sense um where
those things are there's a number of
speculations
for a long long time there's been
speculation off near catalina island in
the uh off the southern coast of
california
it could be
probably a few others probably a bunch
of others
these alien subspecies in the alien
agendas did you well you
at least surmise some of the
relationships that they would have with
us
what about with each other do you know
if there are conflicts among the
potential alien races or species or
whatever we want to call it
not in terms of any actual direct ufo
testimony that i've ever considered
credible i mean you've got
you've got stories coming to various
researchers not to me
but other research i talked to my friend
and colleague linda moulton howe
linda talked about an account that she
had i believe this encounter happened i
totally believe linda on this that she
had in december 1999 with a retired dia
analyst defense intelligence agency
analyst who uh
apparently told linda
about
the us government's monitoring of
multiple
extraterrestrial groups here so
basically um
humanoid human looking beings like look
exactly like us
uh gray type human being you know the
short big eyes big head
um
and then reptilian type beings and
apparently describing to her that there
was like conflict between them or among
them
over mastery of
the human species and earth and it's
like um
you know when i hear that i i've told
this to linda so i can say it here
i just said well
i would be i would be careful about that
because um
you just i have no way to know how true
that is
there you i know you mentioned one of
your
viewers had a question about travis
walton
and uh i'll just jump ahead to that a
little bit and just say like on in his
experience
on that craft that travis
remembered quite well
there were non-human and human beings on
that on that ship
and uh that indicates more of a
cooperation than and hostility now maybe
this is a different non-human group than
what this dia guy was telling linda who
knows like it's very difficult to have a
scorecard here and to know exactly
what's true or not
there's claims all over the place
there's there's for me there are things
that i absolutely can state with
confidence
without question
and then there are things that are
you know that as the late stanton
friedman used to put it i'll put in my
gray basket i don't know if they're true
or not true and i'll just uh hold on to
them for a little while and just wait
and that's where i'm at with uh like the
relationships among these other groups
again i speculate a little bit about
this in my my book the alien agendas
and i speculate
and it does appear to me when i look at
the history of the encounters like with
human looking occupants of ufos for
example
there's a lot of these lots of them i
for many years i tried to ignore that
because i i
i just wasn't comfortable with the idea
of human operators of ufos it just
seemed unlocked illogical to me
but the fact is that there are so many
of these and um
and they don't come from people that i
think are wackos they come from people
that seem to be
logical and um
and sincere and so
you know when you get enough of them it
just doesn't make sense to dismiss them
so when i look at all of those
encounters those those beings do not
they don't seem to do abductions they
don't seem to be doing experimentation
on people they
seem to be
quite a bit more benign
actually than reports of uh like the
classic gray aliens
so i think
and when i look at all the reports of
grey aliens all of them
um
it does seem to me that they take people
they are engaged in biological
manipulation of human species and
creation of what we call hybrids and all
of that
and that they have an agenda
and that is what it looks like to me so
i
i speculate in
in my most recent book that there
could definitely be
either a rivalry or some kind of
competition between the human looking
beings and these greys but
you know again it's all speculation i
feel like you know when you're a ufo
researcher
that we have a lot of problems with
studying this phenomenon hey i mean it's
just difficult on its own terms it's
it's a challenging subject
because it appears to be derived from a
group of people in intelligence or
intelligences that are
more advanced than we are
and so
when we want to apply the scientific
method to understand this
the the problem that you have with that
is that every scientist is assuming that
they're in charge of the equation you
set the protocols you're you're studying
the thing
what if we're not the smartest part of
the equation what if there's a group
that's actually beyond us how do we
control the experiment in a way that is
going to satisfy our ability to do
proper science here
what if we're at a big disadvantage like
that i think that's actually the case so
so it's difficult so it's intrinsically
difficult on top of that
you've got secrecy the secrecy is real
secrecy by these other beings and
secrecy by our own governments
the united states government has a
system of what i call legal illegality
to hide
hide this deeply deeply deeply through
what are called special access programs
within the dod within the department of
energy and within the cia
and it's just never going to get
oversight over you can't get to it you
can't get there from here
you know and so so we've got that so
it's like being a kid pressing your nose
against a darkened window of a candy
store
thinking i'm looking at the candy
you can see a few things but it's it's
not easy and so there's a lot that we
just don't know and i hate that that's
the case but
to me that that looks like the case
josh patterson asks any thoughts from
richard about so-called high strangeness
surrounding ufo encounters fairy lore
correlations consciousness might be
first of all what is high strangeness i
think that's a great question too
high strangeness is a phrase that came
about i think in the 60s maybe the 70s
uh
to
to given a term
to something that a lot of researchers
were beginning to understand
you know you go back to the 1950s and
60s and the assumptions by
the people who were like first looking
at this
first writers
um you know they were working off of
like buck rogers types of uh
concepts in other words we were about to
go into space
and so therefore
the assumption was these other
beings that are operating these craft
were probably space men
maybe some space women
uh in metal ships coming from another
planet
to surveil us and to to check us out
you know like in the movie the day the
earth stood still and things like that
so that was the absolutely the dominant
assumption for more than 20 years i
would say but what that you have though
is that there were enough reports even
in the 50s and certainly in the 60s and
beyond
that were very bizarre where you'd have
cases of missing time or cases in which
uh people's cognitive faculties this
this is extremely common here where you
have an encounter with this an object
like this and
you
don't behave the way you you normally
would think that you behave
uh in other words you might have there
are cases of like flying saucer like
directly above someone and they're just
ridiculously calm
like and then you think back and you're
like why why was i so calm
uh well i think because there's
cognitive and emotional manipulation
going i think they just have that
technology they know how to do it or
there are cases of objects seemingly
coming into and out of reality
disappearing not just disappearing like
taking off instantly but just
disappearing now maybe there's cloaking
technology totally possible but you get
into some of the um
other cases where uh then there's like
claims of interdimensional entities that
can come into and out of reality that's
and these even started in the 60s and
70s where you start getting these types
of reports so
i think that led uh some researchers to
use the phrase high strangeness to
describe or the oz factors another one
like when dorothy goes to oz and
everything's weird
so it's like there's something strange
about ufo phenomenon
that bumps up against our understanding
of what even the nature of reality is
and it challenges our perceptions there
so that's what high strangeness is and
the question i think
it's an important question because
you know one thing that
i've definitely come to believe over the
years that i've looked into this is that
the question to mention consciousness
and
there's no question to me any longer
that
consciousness
is somehow very important to
understanding this phenomenon it's not
the only thing you need to know there's
like straight up technology and there's
a lot of physical
non-consciousness related things
important about this but
definitely
time and again
almost to the point of cliche you'll
have people who will say the being spoke
to me into my mind
it wasn't speaking it wasn't flapping
its gums
that's
in fact honestly if i were to get a
story from someone or report
in which some gray aliens talking i i
would probably be suspicious of it
because like that never is the case it's
always telepathic
uh-huh
always telepathic um
they're having cases of human-looking
beings that have spoken
uh in some cases of them not speaking
and of them being telepathic also
but there's a lot of cases of alleged
telepathy in these encounters
so how do you explain that what's the
physics of telepathy damned if i know
i try to hear michio kaku talk about
this once and i don't think he believes
that there's a science until i don't
think he thinks telepathy is real
uh but i think it is some of the
evidence that it's real that you've seen
that you find most credible just such as
remote viewing telekinesis perhaps
telepathy yeah yeah well remote viewing
and telekine those are fascinating to me
you know i married a remote viewer uh
tracy garbett and uh she's
quite good i mean
her she has her own decent track record
which i'm quite impressed by but i've
spent time i know i know the scientists
who created that remote viewing program
for stanford research institute hal put
off and russell targe i know them both
pretty well
uh i've known john mcmonagle one of the
world's greatest remote viewers i've
talked to joe personally i knew the late
ingo swan i spent an evening and goes
home and
that was very cool for me and i've
talked to lynn buchanan another these
are these are like the classic
heroes of remote viewing and the thing
is when you look in so what is remote
viewing so it was developed in the 1970s
think of it as psychic spying
and
again this is not this is something
that's not supposed to be
not supposed to exist but it does and
they've got a great track record i mean
they've in my view
the track record
of remote viewing is strong enough
there's a recent documentary called
third eye spies which deals with some of
the really good evidence and stories and
like like here
heroic remote views of these people did
it's really quite remarkable
joe mcmonagle most famously one of his
great movies back in 1979
he's
working under skip atwater who ran the
uh project called stargate for the
pentagon remote viewing program so
atwater gives mcmonagle a target and the
way he would give it to him is
latitude longitude coordinates like
exact to the to the second or even
beyond in a sealed envelope
okay
and he'd give the sealed envelope to joe
and say i'd like you to meditate on this
and tell me what you see you don't even
they don't even open the envelope most
of the time it's not like joe's like
look at the latitude and longitude and
guess where this place was no it doesn't
work like that
joe would go in he went into a room he
meditated he said this to me
and he's a good illustrator he's a good
artist and he drew a manufacturing
facility where this massive submarine
was being constructed and he actually
drew the dimensions of it he drew how
many canted tubes that were
that it had and a lot of other things
about he drew also a half completed
submarine over here and this whole thing
and he gave it back to skip and uh they
took that to the national security
council
and uh
one of the members of the nsc at the
time was a younger robert gates who
later became director of the cia in the
in the pentagon himself
but they were all like this is bs like
if this would be the largest submarine
in the world
it was at a soviet manufacturing
facility all right off the i think off
the north sea
and uh they were like how come our
actual spies never gave us any
indication of this
uh actually
so so this turned out to be the soviet
typhoon class submarine which was
featured in the tom clancy's story the
hunt for red october it was not
submarine anyway so mcmonagle gets this
in this back and he says to them well
i don't know but put your
satellites over this i think between 90
and 120 days and you'll see it dockside
and they did and it was and that's what
that was so and robert gates's answer to
that from what i heard was
lucky guess
and uh sorry but i don't i don't
consider that a lucky guess i think that
they're they're for that one story
there's
countless others hundreds of others
and so that tells me
that
we human beings have an ability
and
you know the way put off uh put it to me
was he said look it's like he said i
think of it like musical ability
everyone's got some but some people are
virtuosos and some are just you know
relatively tone deaf but everyone's got
some he believes so everyone can do this
but there's certain training and
protocols that
that their program put people through
it's very
it's very rigorous
and it works doesn't work 100 of the
time they these guys are wrong it's not
like you turn on a tv station and you
can see things perfectly it's not at all
like that
uh they are
they are seeing flashes of things
and some remote viewers are good at
seeing
different things they're not all good at
the same thing
like some musicians are better at
different instruments yes absolutely and
some will see different patterns and
some will see emotions or they'll feel
emotional
and so the way you actually do it if
you're going to run a team is like
you're the you're the handler and then
let's say you've got six remote viewers
and you give them each the same
assignment
and if you're a good manager of your
team like you know what they're each
good at you'll and you get to learn how
to interpret what they do but that's
that's actually how it works as an
intelligence tool
why do you think it is if the evidence
is
somewhat incontrovertible and it seems
like we can perform studies in
controlled settings like this person was
given an envelope and so on so
presumably we could have 10 people
expert at guessing digits
in another room 10 people who are laymen
i guess some target
why is it that the scientific community
at large doesn't believe this evidence
is it a couple of reasons simply scanty
evidence
oh i think in the classified world
there's probably an abundance of
evidence
that's the problem you're dealing with
science works on money science works on
institutional support no one goes off
into their basement and does science
anywhere it's like that's not what that
is
it's alexander graham bell that's not
today so scientists today work in terms
of institutional corporate and
governmental support
and if there's no money there's not
going to be science everyone knows that
so i think if you've got something
that's very deeply classified you think
about this
where the money is abundant within the
black budget world
but this but
but the findings are classified and
there's no public money going into it in
the public world well then yes you're
going to get that attitude to scientists
scientists are just human beings
they're very intelligent
sometimes a little spectrum-y and but
they're brilliant problem solvers and
that doesn't mean that they
you know have the deep wisdom
that
you know i mean i don't think they're
any more deeply wise than the average
person to be honest they they're
brilliant problem solvers if they're
good
and they're employees
and if they if the information's not
presented to them how why would they
possibly think that it's valid
is there another reason outside of this
the reason i'm saying this is that in
1905
einstein wasn't a part of any
institution but then took a couple years
and his theories were accepted a couple
years didn't take decades right however
this seems like it's taking decades and
there's more than just one einstein
there are many people remote viewing
so one question
well i don't have to think about it i
mean einstein did
series of equations
and he showed his work and other
mathematicians were able to check his
work right so
um
i mean i'm not an expert on that whole
process but that's what i'm assuming
with the general or special theories of
relativity but
with uh
with remote viewing
i mean all i can say is that there are
some scientists who very quietly are
intrigued by this but there's a lot of
institutional pressure against them
it's not just with the remote viewing
it's with ufos as well like i will
correspond with
many many retired academic academicians
they're retired
it's like once they're out of that
system they feel much more free to talk
to me about their interest in ufos or
anything else that's weird
while they're in the system
they just don't they absolutely don't
it's very political as everyone knows
and
i i think that's a big part of it the
other part of it is that we we have
a society that has been
i mean this is me being a conspiracy
theorist but i happily wear that hat
i'm not afraid of that phrase uh
back in the 1940s and 50s we had the
beginnings of something that became
known as operation mockingbird and
that's cia management and control over
u.s mainstream media and we know this is
true
there's no question about it no one
talks about it but it was a
it was an active
measure program
to manage u.s public opinion through
the wire services with walter concrete
and you know cbs and abc and all the
major networks new york times washington
post and so forth and we know this is
the case there's no question about it
and mockingbird as a program continues
to this day in fact it's deeper and more
insidious than ever before but it works
that way with the academic community we
know that there's been long-standing
interrelationship between uh
particularly the ivy leagues and the cia
it's a big study called cloak and gown
by the late historian robin winks it
talks about yale and cia for example but
that's just the tip of the iceberg
and we know about it through the
political connections as well there's a
lot of
domination of politicians individually
through bribery and blackmail
so the intelligence community is this
behemoth that no one ever talks about
that has an incredible influence over
not just the ins those institutions i
talked about but through culture itself
and through managing
managing pop culture and also managing
the scientific community we know for
example that the main ufo skeptic for
the 1950s and 60s going into the 70s was
an astronomer at harvard named donald
menzel
after menzel died we learned that he had
highest level nsa security clearances he
was an ex he wasn't just an astronomer
he was an expert
cryptographer
and
was his wife did not even know about his
highest level nsa clearances
so is it a coincidence that you've got
the leading
world debunker of ufos harvard
astronomer
and he's doing he's doing debunking work
on ufos with a connection to the nsa
that no one happened to know about so
that's what i'm saying so you've got so
mental what did he do he was the if
there was some young academic commission
back in those days who wanted to get
into ufos and there were here along
comes menzel and smacks him down who's
going to argue with donald menzel back
then
no one
so you've got you've got guard dogs
managing the herd menzel was one of
those people in my opinion so i think
you can control the culture pretty
effectively that way through fear
intimidation and then the culture just
creates itself
if you're a young grad student
in any department in physics or history
that's my field
and you had an interest in ufos let's
say you wanted to do a dissertation on
it
simple question
who who would be qualified to oversee
that dissertation there's no one there's
no one in those fields who really know
anything so it's a self-perpetuating
cycle
so there's a lot of things that go into
it but i think it starts
with
institutional
heavy-handed
uh ridicule and career-ending things
career-ending policies back from the
1940s and 50s that was absolutely the
case and it i think it just continued
and deepened
okay this question comes from tyler
goldstein who has a theory of everything
this channel is about theories of
everything called the theory of everyone
his question is
did richard does richard dolan believe
that sleep paralysis could often be
caused artificially by the beings
responsible for the ufo phenomenon
thanks to you both for exploring such
difficult topics
yes yes i do i think i think um
there are many
this is anecdotal based on witness
testimony and claims but nonetheless
uh lots of lots of cases almost
typically where people will
state
that uh
they were taken and their partner was
switched off
or they were in an automobile and all
the other people in the car were
switched off paralyzed essentially you
have cases you don't even have to have
an abduction experience there there is a
case from a famous one from france in
1965 valencial case
a guy named maurice maas is a lavender
farmer at the time and he's he sees a
landed craft
moss you know everything that i learned
about him he was a highly respected man
in his community
a
former french resistance fighter during
the second world war anyway so he sees a
landed craft in this lavender field it's
a flying saucer
he goes out there he sees two short
beings and they aim a device at him and
he's paralyzed he's standing
in the field he can't move and he's
watching them they're
doing soil samples or whatever the hell
they're doing
he actually even thought that they
almost laughed at him
or were giggling at him
that was his impression
they get into the craft they leave and
with a couple of minutes after that he
regains use of his body so he was
standing upright
frightened i think so yeah i think he
was standing or just paralyzed yeah
standing so he
kept a sense of balance i suppose and
was able
that's a good question like if you're
totally paralyzed and standing i think
you'd fall over
yeah that's extremely
that's
impossible
very good way to put it
so i don't know how that worked and i
can't pretend that i understand but i
thought the story like you know you look
at moss his uh
his life and the people who vouched many
people to vouch for him in his village
so but there's the thing about the
paralysis is that um
comes up a lot
now you got to be careful with sleep
paralysis because we all know
the argument that
many people have brought out to describe
the abduction phenomenon as nothing
other than
uh fantasy
hypno hypnopomic i think
illusions based on sleep paralysis and
you can say that except for the fact
that there are just too many abduction
cases that do not involve people lying
in their beds and they're not asleep
so i don't really know how to explain
that i don't think that's a good
catch-all at all
this one comes from politically
incorrect
he or she asks does richard think that
does richard think there's any relation
to the paul
benowitz case and the recent revelations
what does he think
is or was going on at mount
archuleta
yeah wow i've been to mount archuleta
that's in uh near dulce new mexico
uh paul benowitz of course is a for
those who don't know
so back in the late 1970s paul bennowitz
was a very highly accomplished uh
scientist who had defense contracts with
the pentagon
and he lived and worked
just facing kirtland air force base
in albuquerque so he observed and over
there you also have the manzano weapons
storage facility where they
had a lot of nukes down there
and benowitz is seeing a lot of strange
things over
over kirtland
that seemed to him to be like ufos and
so he's a patriotic american
and he actually contacts kirtland
and says look there's things going on
over there
and
you damn will
be on top of this because
this is important
they send an air force intelligence
officer richard dodi who is also very
well known
and dodi investigates and he he realizes
that benowitz is very
probably seeing us tech
some advanced us tech
now that's the argument i actually think
benowitz was seeing some advanced us
tech and he might have been seeing
something more
it's my own opinion anyway one thing
that dodie did
he wanted his main mission was to get
benowits off of the
u.s projects that were
being developed there
like this was a security leak
and the problem was bennowitz was a nice
guy no one wanted to mess up paul
benowitz but they had to
they had to make sure that he was not
going to be reporting
about advanced united states weapon
systems that were there so that was a
prime importance to them and dodi was
primarily responsible for that so one
thing dodie did is he took benowitz
uh
and this is to kind of throw him off of
kirtland and to bring him to another
place he bring he flies them up to
dulce new mexico and they go over mount
archuleta
to give benowitz this idea that there
were there was an alien base there
and
bennowitz did you know get into this
whole idea that there was an alien base
at mount archuleta so the question is so
there was a disinformation campaign
essentially
the questionnaire is asking about what's
going on today so
i hear this a lot so the group ttsa to
the stars academy
uh
which was
head fronted back in 2017 by the pop
star tom de long of the group blink 182
but tom delong
also brought in a number of very
senior and impressive individuals on his
team so louise elizondo hal put off
christopher mellon
um
and uh
you know a number of others
engineers high level people at lockheed
and elsewhere okay and and so what they
did is they began putting out starting
in 2017 ufo related information
they were able to get two stories
published in the new york times by
leslie kane and ralph blumenthal
in december of 2017 they talked about
the atip program and talked about the
tic tac ufo and and to the stars put out
other information as well
uh
and the question arises are they
disinformation you know a lot of guys
with intelligence backgrounds are they
just out to feed the public a line of
something with a view of manipulating
them for some purpose the most common
theory is that because you have elizondo
occasionally talking about these things
as a potential threat to national
security the idea is that are they
trying to scare up the public
to get them to run to the military for
protection and then you can like pump up
the military budget even more
um or for some other kind of false flag
or some kind of
uh
fear-mongering exercise
and and that's what many people have
accused them of doing
i'm not one of those people and i don't
i don't have that accusation at all i
don't i don't think they're doing a
false flag it doesn't mean that they
don't have their own agenda
that doesn't mean that they're not
secretive they are
but uh but that's because they've all
got security clearances and they just
can't talk about certain things
uh to talk about ufos as a potential
threat is a completely valid point in my
opinion
uh i mean look these are military people
every hammer is going to look like an
every every
hammer every solution looks like a nail
and to a military guy
when you have objects that are unknown
hanging out over your weapons
installations and security places that
no one's supposed to go to
what are you supposed to do other than
think of it as a potential threat like
that's your job you're supposed to do
that and i just think that's what
elizondo's doing is his job does that
mean they're gonna do an independence
day and blow up the white house no
probably not
but that doesn't mean that they can't be
considered a threat so i don't i
actually don't buy the criticism that
they're engaged in a disinfo
like a cia disinfo program i've looked
for that evidence personally i don't see
it personally i don't believe it they do
have intelligence community backgrounds
that is true
and so but but i judge them based on is
the information that they put out true
or not true that's first
well seems to be true is the information
they put out relevant or irrelevant well
it seems to be relevant is it is it new
have they added to our ability as a
society have intelligent conversations
about ufos and the answer is they
absolutely have now is there another
agenda that we can speculate about
yes there's always a potential agenda we
can speculate about but we don't i don't
know what that is and i don't want to
spend my time trying to crawl inside
their head and act like i know what
they're trying to do better than they
know what they're trying to do agenda on
behalf of the aliens or the us
government doing the revelations
say that again when you said that you
don't want to speculate on the agenda
whose agenda are you referring to on
ttsa so uh
tom delong elizondo chris mellon
and steve justice and and all of those
and put off uh
you know i know put off personally and i
have i've tried to pry whatever
information i can out of him for 20 plus
years and
you know he keeps his cards very close
to his vest always always he's hal over
the years has given me a lot of
interesting information
and that's
checked out as far as i can tell
uh we have a rapport i think that i
believe him
on the things he tells me he doesn't
overdo it he's never stretched
my view
um i've talked to chris mellen i've
talked to luella zondo and i've i've
never i've not found them to be
dishonest with me
they don't tell everything they know but
for me to speculate on their ulterior
motivations
i just feel like that's the kind of
world we're in the ufo community
it's one thing to be critically minded
you want to be that it's even another
thing to be suspicious
that's fine too but when you are so
suspicious that it goes to knee-jerk
paranoia every time new information
comes out and you declare every new
thing that you encounter to be a hoax or
disinfo then i think you got a problem
because the thing that you're not doing
it seems to me is actually studying the
content of what the other person is
trying to say
and when you when you're not doing that
then we're breaking down as a society
because then we're doing what everyone
else in the world is doing you're
judging people based on who they are and
what you think their associations are
rather than what they're saying
and what you're not doing is having
conversation
so so i i don't want to contribute to
that so when tdsa or any of the members
of that have something to say
i want to listen to what they have to
say and i want to be able to examine it
and decide
is this true and relevant or is it not
true and relevant is it deceptive
things like that but so far you know
they haven't flunked my test
so i
i will support them to the extent that
they put out information that's valid
and useful and contributes to the public
conversation on ufos
it's a it's a fact that all of those
people know many many many more things
than they are saying publicly
absolutely true
but what am i going to blame them for
that
they they can't then they can't they
can't break the law
yeah i know what you mean when you say
that there are large swaths of this ufo
community that ex-postulate certain
members which i find
to be interesting because
the community as a whole is already
ostracized and then it's fractionated
within it so some people criticize me
for having you on or for having jeremy
corbell on or louis elissando oh you had
jeremy and lou elizondo on yeah it was
there were wonderful conversations
people if you're watching this and you
would like to watch them the links are
in the description yes
and like a part of me understands it
because this phenomenon is so near and
dear to the people who study it that
they don't want people who they see as
unreputable or disreputable
to be getting some of the limelight but
at the same time
the reason why i'm not hitting you with
questions like well what's the evidence
of so-and-so like the traditional
skeptic would would because be because
first of all i can predict you're you're
primarily going to say we don't have
hard evidence or hard proof it's not
like the sciences and second of all i'm
trying to ask you from the perspective
of what if what you're saying is true
and i just need to i just want to
understand how are you coming at this
how are you arriving at your conclusions
i don't see that same
open-mindedness in this community that
should well that's false i'm being
extremely i'm generalizing but there are
some people in this community who
denigrate completely other people in the
community whether you have a listening
rather than listening to their arguments
but i also understand it at the same
time a lot of people are keyboard
warriors
they don't publish anything they just
follow
and you know
these some of these are the perennial
guys who live in mom's basement and they
got no other life i mean that's the
truth
so
but they can they can be very loud and
prominent
and um
and they and it can make people think
that
you know is if someone who does that who
just trash talks on someone under a
pseudonym
which a lot of these people will do like
is that a legitimate part of the
community or not well they kind of force
their way in and because they're loud
enough they can make it seem like
they're a part of the community but are
they really i don't know who these
people are i don't want to engage in a
debate with anyone if they're hiding
behind a suit on them that's for sure
why the hell would i want to play that
game
so
there are people like that and we have a
society in which mental illness has gone
way up
we have a society in my view that that
inculcates and increasingly fosters
mental illness of all types and i think
that will only increase not decrease as
the decades move on
so we have we have real problems like we
have a society that is by its nature
psychologically dysfunctional and so you
get
and when you have marginalized
communities in the ufo community has
always been marginalized
um there's two things like one thing is
it will it will draw certain unstable
people to it
because it is fringe
uh
now not everyone who's unstable
some people may be unstable because they
had an encounter that they don't know
how to process
that could absolutely be the case
but there
i i once uh
ten years ago maybe i i talked about
something i called the uh was it the
broken
the damaged goods syndrome
a lot of people in in who drawn to ufos
are damaged good psychologically it's
sad i mean i don't i don't make fun of
such people you meet them all the time
and i have i have only empathy and
compassion for them but there's many
there's something it you know they're
looking for an answer
everyone wants to look for an answer
everyone feels broken inside everyone
feels like there's something missing in
my life
and and some of those people
they know there's something wrong with
our society they feel it in their bones
and they're right there is something
wrong you've got we have we have a
society that has many many secrets to it
true
and
they will gravitate to ufos and some of
those people are brilliant but sometimes
they can get really worked up
they're not all psychologically stable i
mean that's unfortunately the case and
so i think that's part of it and um
it's also true look
there are bots there
never ever underestimate the power of
the intelligence community to screw up a
field
don't we all right
what do you mean you said there are bots
as in
farms yeah fake fake people
you know we remember snowden's
revelations weren't that long ago it was
less than 10 years ago
and one of the things we learned from
snowden is that
you troll farms exist
gchq of the uk that's their nsa
and i think the nsa itself i think it
came out like we they insert them so
they have
people on the payroll
who pretend to be normal genuine people
except they're not
they may have 10 different persona that
they'll go around and just trash talk in
various communities that they want to
disrupt
[ __ ] the fbi was doing this with
co-intel pro back in the 1960s
you'd have people going in and
infiltrating groups hoover was all over
this this is an old game
you have ajahn provaka tours joseph
foucher uh back under napoleon
began this technique over 200 years ago
it's nothing new
so
that exists so
i don't want to encourage paranoia here
but the fact is that
we don't we don't know who all these
people are so when you're talking about
a community that is at war with itself
and that is absolutely true
there's a lot of factors involved it's
unfortunate
i don't know what to do for myself other
than
i try to avoid the fights i try to i
never get personal
i never ever get personal for me i try
to stay on there's an old statement a
young lewis armstrong got from his
mentor king oliver
armstrong was doing those great solos in
the early 20s and oliver said stick to
the main line kid in other words don't
get cute
remember what it's about it's about the
song
and as a researcher it's about
it's about the
phenomenons not about other
researchers i don't want to go in and
start having wars with other people it's
a great way to waste your time
but unfortunately it's true you think do
you go foes are bad go to the
look into the 911 research community
good grief those people are terrifying
they are at war with each other every
day
so there's a lot of fringe communities
out there where
you have um
people accusing each other of being
agents and being you know disinfo and
all that it's
a lot of hatreds and and all too often
like i've been criticized many times
i've done i did a couple of new ag
conferences i got invited to i'm not a
i'm not a new ager
you know but i've gone i've spoken there
i've done interviews with people who are
some of them i think are kind of off the
wall one second richard what do you
define as new age because some people
would say remote viewing and telekinesis
are right at the top
oh no no they need to get a little bit
of an education i don't think they know
what new age is then if they think that
is i would say
uh
do a little more research than that no
i'm talking about you know
california coast crowd where it's all
about creating your own reality and um
wearing the flowing robes and i mean
there's a whole culture with that look
and right so i've done a number of
events with people who are just like
that some of them are wonderful people
you know they're great i mean i don't
agree with their
uh all of their philosophy
but i'll go in because my attitude is i
want to go in and if there's new people
that i can reach like with your
community a lot of the folks who follow
you they don't know who i am
but there's always someone new out there
and i'm always happy to talk to a new
group
and but i've been criticized for it
that's my point like there's people i
see he appeared on stage with this
person
and that's a bad person so now he's a
bad person and i just think yeah guilt
by association yeah that's a really
dangerous thing and we do it all too
often in our society
and it's super dangerous it's a great
way to destroy a
society way to do that i'm in a similar
position as you
well actually i'm an outsider so i don't
know who to trust or who not to trust i
go by the comments section and i try to
talk to the people that i try to go
straight to the source but like you
mentioned some people there are many
things the main thing you have to do i
don't mean to i want you to finish it
but the main thing anyone has to do
especially if they've got good critical
thinking skills not everyone does
but if you do and i'm sure you do then
you go by your judgment you go by your
assessment which i'm sure you do in the
long run
right i i have to extreme sympathy for i
know we just mentioned that the
community is at war within itself for at
itself i have sympathy for much of these
people much of whom aren't anonymous the
reason why is that i see them as caring
so deeply about this subject that as
soon as
they question the credibility of someone
they
vehemently attack them
out of love much of the time it's not
out of hate for the person it's out of
love for the phenomenon
so they're trying to maintain its
integrity
so i understand it i don't
well i understand it and then i
i dislike it in some respects and i
understand it in another
i think i think look you got to be
humble before the ufo phenomenon you
better be humble
in other words
this is a very difficult subject i i'm
in a position where i i had a great
formal education before i got into ufos
really very strong
and after that i
continued on as uh
independently learning like and plus i
never worked for another company i
always worked for myself sometimes
making just scraping by with nothing but
i did it so i was always dedicated to
this and it's still difficult for me
like i have a difficult time
figuring a lot of things out and i think
like if if i
if it's hard for me
who has i have made the time i've set
aside the entire my entire life
so i think
you know it's complicated it's difficult
and so i i never want to pretend that
i've got the answers the ufo subject is
like some master on a hill that you go
to learn from like some zen master in a
cave and you want to learn from you
don't just walk in and say teach me
everything you know
like how arrogant
and yet that's what people often think
about ufos ufos is that zen master this
phenomenon is that great teacher but you
go in with humility
don't go in like you think you're going
to figure it all out when i started in
the early 90s
i was in a bookstore
i saw a classic ufo book called above
top secret the worldwide ufo cover-up
talked about this many times by the
writer timothy goode
and i thought wow worldwide ufo cover-up
this is the
1983 and um
i flipped through it i was like this is
a this is a pretty good book i bought it
i was gonna figure this all out in three
months
i just i just wanted to resolve for
myself
are ufos a real thing or not a real
thing and i thought i can figure this
out in a couple of months and then i
would move on with my life well right
that was my arrogance at the time i
thought you know and it just it doesn't
work like that um it's this is something
that's very very fascinating challenging
difficult
and the more you dive in the more nuance
you find
so i'm not
it always
like it's distressing i don't want to
say distressing it's just it's
unfortunate that there's a lot of folks
out there who are absolutely convinced
that they've got everything figured out
and there's no room for a good faith
debate
you're watching this channel because
you're interested in theoretical physics
consciousness and the ostensible
connection between the two what's
required to follow some of these
arguments is facility with mathematics
as well as discernment of the underlying
physical laws and you may think that
this is beyond you but that's false
brilliant provides perlucid explanations
of abstruse phenomenon such as quantum
computing general relativity and even
group theory when you hear that the
standard model is based on u1 cross su 2
cross su 3 that's group theory for
example now this isn't just for
neophytes either for example i have a
degree in math and physics and i still
found some of the intuitions given in
these lessons to vastly aid my
penetration into these subjects for
example electricity and magnetism sign
up today at brilliant.org
tow that is t-o-e for free you'll also
get 20 off the annual premium
subscription try four of the lessons at
least don't stop before four and i think
you'll be greatly surprised at the ease
at which you comprehend subjects you
previously had trouble grocking links
are in the description this person named
xcaliperful
asks what does richard think
are the top uap cases for academic study
with partial data sets accessible to the
public
cool
several
i would say
um
white sands proving ground in oh god i
need the date
1942 april 49
when they say data and and things like
this so
data by whom so what we know is we have
declassified us government documents
i take those as data
scientists might not i don't know what a
scientist would do
but when i have us government documents
talking about
a missile and u.s navy missile launch in
april of 1949 in which a missiles has
achieved the speed of
1300 miles per hour and at which point a
film captures two white objects circling
around it
and then
zooming off
uh
to me that's that's interesting i think
that's april 24 1949.
that's a heck of a case another one um
that's not a military one might be uh
known as the jlw07 case from 1986 that's
a
alaskan airlines japan excuse me japan
airlines uh
over alaska over kind of almost over the
north pole
uh
this is not a commercial flight it was a
it was not an airliner flight it was a
commercial flight they were importing i
think bringing over expensive french
wine
and you have for 29 minutes
i think it is
the
pilot and co-pilot
on their radar and visually and then you
have ground-based radar at two places in
alaska tracking an object
that was even men's size that detached
two smaller objects that just
were in front of the aircraft for a long
period of time
um
you've got the
is this a scientific data set or not the
1976 september 76 tehran iran iranian
case
one of the most famous cases where
you have uh two successive f4 iranian
pilots
engaging
an object that disabled their
electronics and avionics equipment uh on
on the ship when they were trying to
engage in this object one was about to
fire an aim-9 missile at it when a
second before he's about to push the
button the controls went off
this object was just there
it then according to the pilot who later
became a general in the iranian air
force
moved from point to point across the sky
i don't know if that's a data set that
this person's asking for
i mean what you have are
very well documented military cases
that
i can't dismiss them
i can't i can't just say he didn't know
what he's talking about i've heard
skeptical assessments of these which are
to me just totally unpersuasive
totally unpersuasive
um
i don't know the person asked for five i
gave three sorry
there's more i just you know sure that's
fine matthew clevenger says what do you
think about the experiment at skinwalker
ranch that's another subject i'm
extremely interested at skinwalker ranch
and the new info on portals i don't know
what that new information i don't know
what they're referring to i don't know
okay matthew if you can at me so that i
can see it explain what you mean by the
new info on portals either way he wants
to know what you think about the
experiments going on at skinwalker ranch
oh hell skin walker so you have uh
billionaire robert bigelow back in the
early 1990s forms an organization called
the national institute for discovery
science nids
he brings help hud off on we mentioned
put off
dr kit green formerly of the cia very
interesting man i know kit
john alexander
eric davis
brilliant physicist colm kelleher
another brilliant scientist
and they one of the things they settle
on is
this place called the sherman ranch in
utah and uh it had a long history of
alleged paranormal activity and they
they called skinwalker ranch because i
think it was the ute uh tribe
uh
talked about these beings called
skinwalkers these
and um
and was associated with this property so
what you have with skinwalker is
a long
multi-year
and in fact it's
been revisited skinwalkers you know the
tv show unidentified the ttsa creation
basically
they returned to skinwalker
but back in the 90s when uh
they were
going full guns on this with their
instrumentation
[Music]
they were tracking a lot of very bizarre
phenomenon there
not just ufo sightings there were cases
of ufos there but there were cases of
uh portals
or apparent portals or alleged portals
there were cases of
uh crypt kryptoid type creatures that
weren't supposed to exist like the dire
wolf like this massive well
apparently
the owner of the branch took several
shots at this thing and all he did was
piss it off and it just grumpily turned
around and walked away after he
loaded it with i think he had a shotgun
um
there is
you know
jeremy corbell who you interviewed did a
documentary on skinwalker ranch it's
called skinwalker the best part about
that documentary in my view is the old
footage that the journalist george knapp
acquired back in the 1990s on some of
it's fascinating there's a cattle
mutilation case at skimwalker in the 90s
that is absolutely just baffling makes
no sense
how that could have happened the way
that it did so you've got a case where
it's believed
and there were other things they had
like classic almost poltergeist activity
going on at the house according to
george knapp and colm keller who wrote
the book on this the hunt for the
skinwalker
so there's a lot of strange things going
on there
people say it's a portal you know where
where the
i don't know how do you the the layer
between our world and the other world is
thin and
is it can that be true yeah i don't know
i'm not i'm not the physicist who can
say yes or no this is true but
something very strange about that
property without a doubt
is there any relationship between ufos
and bigfoot
some people might say yes um i don't i
don't know what that i would say yes or
no on that there are a few researchers
if you talk to bigfoot researchers and
i've talked to a few of them
they're interesting people you got a
felony lauren coleman out in portland
maine
coleman's quite experienced very
knowledgeable man yeah it would help me
actually if you went through some of the
people you considered to be most
credible in the bigfoot field later
we'll talk well i just named lauren and
i think he is lorien lauren coleman
without a doubt
he runs he runs a i think it's a bigfoot
or like a cryptid museum
in portland it's a cool place
very cool place
uh
there's another
another older researcher named stan
gordon of western pennsylvania who
equally has done ufos and sasquatch or
bigfoot sightings in western
pennsylvania in fact stan wrote a book
called
on the year nine on one year on the year
1973 in which he compiled uh ufo and
bigfoot
sightings in western pennsylvania
because he was following them and he put
them together and it was stan's
contention that they are related
there's another researcher who i think
might not
agree with that and that's dr jeffrey
meldrum who uh teaches
where the hell is he teaching idaho
jeffrey meldrum's his phd
they they try to get him out they try to
like run him out of his university but
they can't because he's got tenure and
he's done a lot of very detailed big uh
set he doesn't use the board bigfoot he
calls it sasquatch but he does
tremendous amount of research on that so
within that community you've got a split
you've got the people there who believe
that all these cryptids
these cryptozoological creatures are
simply natural earthquakes like the
coelacanth when that was discovered in
the 1930s everyone thought it had been
extinct for millions of years and then
they find it holy crap we got one of
these things you know from the age of
the dinosaurs or whatever here it is so
there are people who believe that
bigfoot
or the yeti you know
that maybe it's just a
an evolved species on our planet that
right is very secretive so that's one
school of thought
and i don't i don't want to speak for
jeffrey meldrum here because i could be
wrong
but
my impression is he he might be leaning
toward that school
definitely stan gordon
does not
and i don't know what lauren coleman
thinks
you'll have to ask him but anyway um
then there are people who do argue that
there's a definite paranormal
element to sasquatch or bigfoot whether
they connect it to ufos
i don't know i don't know how they they
think of it do they think he's the
interdimensional entity i mean you
definitely hear this a lot what does it
even mean to be an interdimensional
entity who the hell knows i try to
understand what's another dimension how
is it possible that there's a membrane
here and just right like six inches from
my nose is another universe i i hear
this
i don't know how to understand that idea
frankly my common sense just recoils but
you've got all these theories about
interdimensionality
okay so maybe that's true
but
you know
what do i think i don't i don't know
what i think i've talked to bigfoot
witnesses
they're every bit as compelling as a ufo
witness there's no difference
none in my opinion so i mean i you you
talked to these guys
one of them said to me he was out in
oregon in the forest he's like i was 60
feet away from this thing he's a hunter
he was like in his mid-30s sharp guy
like seemed very honest i was hunting
i see this bigfoot
and i said the natural question well how
do you know it wasn't a bear he said
because we don't have brown bears here
we have black bears this was brown so
secondly
i know what bears are this wasn't a pear
he's just like well i don't know what to
tell you i'm 60 feet away that's less
than that's the distance from the
pitcher's mound to home plate
you can get a pretty good view of
something in that distance
and uh
he said it looked at me it stood
straight up i was scared out of my mind
i started backing away slowly he said
and it just turned around and walked
away walked away that's his story
am i gonna call him a liar i don't i
don't call him a liar i've talked to
several other
bigfoot witnesses they
they seem to be as on point as ufo
witnesses so who am i to tell them that
they're lying
i don't know what to make of it i don't
know what to make of it
this next question comes from steven
cambion
he wants to know
how do you feel about your participation
in this cia death bed confession
interview i'm unsure what that is but
many people keep referencing that in the
comments section now that other
researchers have proven quote-unquote
that man was not who he said he was and
never worked for the military or cia
oh wow
i guess i should get up on top of that
one um i'll just say this look
i met him i met his son-in-law i got to
know his son-in-law pretty well
this man had been a witness uh back in
the 90s for linda moulton howe
um yeah maybe he was just pulling a yarn
i mean the way it happened look i can't
i can't know before i
before i go in to interview someone
every every single way it's going to
turn out
and i can't be you can't make me like
apologize for every if i make a mistake
i've made mistakes
what am i supposed to do go cower into a
cave like it just happened so this man
um
if that's true i i promised this because
i
actually didn't know i wasn't on top of
this so i'll look into it and
if that's the case i'll make i'll make
my own statement but the thing is i
wasn't
i never really knew what to make of it i
was asked in uh 2013 very beginning of
2013.
to interview this man i was told he was
an important witness i'm like well okay
it was actually linda's case and i
i didn't want to take it but the
impression that i got which turned out
to be not true
was that linda
wasn't going to do it turns out linda
just didn't know that it was being done
i think she would have easily done it
so i
i went up there he was in northern
minnesota
and i went with a few other people i'll
leave their names off ron the late ron
garner who he's no longer with us he was
the one who really pushed this case and
um
i was like all right well i'll interview
him i did my best to get on top of it
i met with him he was a very sweet man i
thought he was gonna die in front of me
like during this interview his health is
terrible
but i will tell you this i spoke to his
son-in-law who was a theology student at
the time these are very like he's a good
people
and the son said yep i've heard this
man's story for years uh he's never
wavered
so all i did was i interviewed him
and i did my best you know
sometimes the best isn't good enough
uh i didn't i didn't go through a
detailed background check of him no i
didn't
you know
so if it's been proven to be a mistake
then well
these are the breaks
all right i'll do my best i'll do people
keep mentioning the wilson
the wilson memo oh there's another
question from great there's another
question from steve campbell please
first can you also let me know what the
wilson memos are people who are
unacquainted you need to know and
listeners need to know great great and
then the question is admirable admiral
wilson has called the wilson documents a
total fabrication and said that he
couldn't have been in the states
the so-called meetings took place in
and so on right okay
so there's that yeah right
wilson has to do that i'm sorry but he
has to do that and and for people who
still doubt this look
there is way too much to put together
and i would i tell them to go to an
article by juliana marinkovic who
actually put together all of the
statements
and all of the evidence about this long
before this thing leaked out in 2019
statements by edgar mitchell for example
so this is the story this is what
happened and we know this all of this
happened i talked about admiral wilson
back in 2007 2008 2009-2010
because i knew about this back then
so what happened is this is a story in
april this is the true story in april
1997 dr stephen greer
who's a ufo researcher he's making the
rounds in dc
and greer is trying to
talk to anyone in dc and positions of
power who are willing to listen to him
about what he considered to be
uh runaway black budget programs dealing
with et tech beyond the purview beyond
the
control of the united states government
but greer believed that they were rogue
programs and he actually had uh the code
name of uh i think at least one of them
so he's going in and he and because he's
accompanied by astronaut edgar mitchell
of apollo 14
and also a navy commander named willard
miller
that got him enough cachet to get a
meeting with admiral thomas wilson
who at the time was deputy head of
intelligence for the joint chiefs of
staff this is april 1997.
so they get a meeting and wilson
actually is not alone there he's he's
with his boss who's general pat hughes
who was uh
one step above him and there was another
admiral i can't remember that admiral's
name offhand
so they they have this meeting and greer
gives his presentation
meeting ends
and uh miller
navy commander stays behind talks to
wilson
for a little while and they talk about
ufos
uh there's a there's an interview with
greer and miller from i think 2013.
where they actually talk about this
meeting
in a limited way but they were like oh
yeah i remember this and wilson's like
yes
hold the next meeting hold the next
meeting i want to talk i want to talk to
these guys and he kept canceling the new
meetings it's this it's a youtube video
and you can hear them discussing this
but anyway so miller and wilson talk
about this after the fact they're
talking and they talk about ufo cover up
what wilson said to greer is that he
would look into this
and uh and he did
uh so for the next two months he
gets advice from different people in the
pentagon including former secretary of
defense william perry who just retired
from that position
and he goes through uh a group known as
alstad and within that called sapoc that
special access program oversight
committee sapoc
and he finds out that within that within
those special access programs these are
black budget programs that have
little to no oversight that nested
within one and within that one and then
within that would like so within one
within another with another he found
what he believed he was looking for
and he called he actually makes a phone
call to the program manager of this it's
a private contractor it's probably
lockheed martin
and he says
you have a program that seems to deal
with a subject that i need to have
oversight over and you are
negligent
because you don't have because i'm not
overseeing this you know we'll simply
was again deputy
head of intelligence for the joint
chiefs and he thought he had he thought
he had oversight he was wrong he didn't
so the program manager says uh i'll get
back to you let me talk to my colleagues
and we'll see what we do
so he gets back to him he says well
we're
we're not going to have a phone
conversation but you can meet with us
and wilson flies out yes i know wilson
has said he's never went out there
so well actually wilson
wilson did not say that wilson said he
never met with eric davis for the
interview but anyway
wilson goes out
and
he meets with them they tell him
yes we're reverse engineering an alien
or a craft that is not made by human
hands not by
not by man not of this world
and we've made painfully slow progress
in understanding it wilson says well i
want and they're like no you're not
coming in
he says well you're wrong they show him
a list of known as the big atlas
b-i-g-o-t derived from world war ii
doesn't mean bigotry it means something
totally different
and
that's a list of who's in and who's out
or who's in
and it's roughly 500 people
and he notices they're all corporate
contractors almost none of them are dod
people
and he says well i need in and they're
like no you're not coming in well what
are your criteria well we don't have to
tell you our criteria except you're not
in well i'm going to go complain they
said be our guest complain see see what
we'll see if we care
and uh they actually said the only
reason we're meeting with you now is
because
we were nearly outed a few years ago
during the pentagon audit and we had the
auditor
uh nearly exposed us and we had to read
him in and we're we're dealing with you
we've actually tightened our security
measures since then
and it's true william perry did a total
re-arg of the dod back in 1993-94
so um anyway so wilson goes back and he
does complain and he's threatened with
his career and it pisses him off but
he's like what can i do
so he's he was told like if you want to
complain you will take an early
retirement you'll probably lose a couple
of stars along the way and don't think
about becoming head of dia so he played
bald he became head of dia and then five
years later he retires and this is what
happens in five years in 2002 eric davis
is
so mitch so mitchell was part of greer's
team keep that in mind so edgar mitchell
knew about this he had gotten feedback
that wilson went on his wild goose chase
for two months
wilson probably talked to will miller
about this that is my best guess he
might have talked to mitchell about it
as well
mitchell reports back to his people who
are his people the nids people under
robert bigelow mitchell was on the board
so was put off so was kid green so was
eric davis all of these people
they are all of them
what is their mission their mission they
want to get to the center of the
labyrinth that's all they want to do
they they have security clearances they
know kid green's another one they know a
lot but they don't know everything that
they want to know that's that's the fact
so they send
so they knew about this for five years
through mitchell
and in 2002 when mitchell when wilson
retired from the dia
goes into private industry it might have
even been before he got hired by atk
um which is where he got hired
davis
eric davis is sent out to interview
wilson
and
yes i know that wilson denied being out
there and i just i don't believe him at
all
davis goes and he hits a home run
interview he sits with wilson he writes
13 pages of notes that are type written
13 pages
wilson davis wilson dave they're
paraphrased notes but they're detailed
because that's how davis is he's a
brilliant physicist he's extremely
detail-oriented where i spoke to him
he might he might have recorded it he
might have transcribed it just from
those i don't know
so what does he do
he gives it to his colleagues and knits
he gives it to green and putt off and
mitchell
and all those guys in 2006
long time ago
one of those people showed me those
notes
okay
i was shown two pages or possibly three
pages and i've never been able to figure
out was it two or three
i was shown part of the transcript
by one of those individuals and i i will
not and have not and will not give up
his name because he's asked me not to if
he dies i'll give up his name
still alive
the point is so yeah it wasn't mitchell
because mitchell did die
however i was shown the part of the
transcript explicitly where it said this
stuff was not made by man not by human
hands was not of this earth
and by the way in a in a 2007
podcast i did with uh the parrot what
was it called gene steinberg's the
paracast i actually was talking about
this
and i didn't say that i had seen pages
by the way because i didn't want to give
that up either but i actually didn't i
used the phrase not made by man not by
human hands i was
referring explicitly to it that's in a
2007 interview from july 1st by the way
someone can hunt that down
so anyway i saw those pages
and
but you know they stayed
they stayed um hidden for years
and i talked about it for a few years
and then i talked about it less and less
and i was like i still i still i was
talking about in in the end of 2018 the
interview with jimmy church asked me
uh what was the biggest story that i
knew that i've never really talked a lot
about and i brought this up and at that
point i mentioned that i was shown pages
of a document
what i didn't know at that time was that
they were actually circulating among the
smallest handful of people at that time
because mitchell had died
i think in early 2017
and when he died
and i still want to be careful about how
i describe this but when he died
some of his papers were going to be
thrown into a dumpster
that believe it or not
and someone very close to edgar mitchell
said no please let me take them and the
member of the family said fine take them
and he took them and in those papers
among those papers were these notes that
eric davis had written up back in 2002
the notes that i had been shown two two
pages of back in oh six
exact same thing
it leaked grant cameron researchers saw
it in november of 2018.
i think i gave my interview with jimmy
church in december of 2018 if i'm not
mistaken
but i didn't know grant had it and uh
and then in april of 2019 someone sent
them to me via a proton mail account
that they'd set up
they were on an imgur page imguar is how
do you pronounce it so it was just a
bunch of jpegs that you that were not
searchable
and so you had right a very very few
people
who had access to this but i i saw that
link and i was like
oh my dear god this is exactly what i
was shown
back in 06.
so i knew it was i knew it was the real
deal i knew it was the real deal but
then i thought well i don't want to leak
at myself like i didn't want to be that
guy
and grant didn't either i talked to
grant about it he's like well now you're
in the box i'm in what are you going to
do
so my plan was i was going to wait i was
going to wait a limited amount of time
and if no one else leaked them i was
just hoping someone else would leak them
i didn't want to be the one to do it
but i i decided if no one else was going
to leak them within maybe by the summer
was what i was thinking maybe late
summer i decided i would i would do it
and i would just take the
[ __ ] storm that would happen as a result
of that
but fortunately for me i mean i didn't i
wasn't the one who leaked it and i
actually don't know to this day i don't
know who that person was but i saw in
early june of 2019 on a
limited email
list that i was part of
uh
that people were talking about this
that document and at that moment i
thought i'm just gonna i'm just gonna do
this so i wrote and put out a youtube
video
in which i called this the ufo leak of
the century
which i believe it is to this day
and um
and that's when you know you've got
people you know look with respect to
some individuals out there i just don't
think that they've really studied this
edgar mitchell talked about by the way
so after we go back to 2006
after this person showed me those
pages of that document i read
uh stephen greer's recent book which was
recent at the time called hidden truth
forbidden knowledge in which
he mentions this and he mentioned wilson
by name
and
i wrote back to my
guy who had showed this to me
and i said oh it's wilson he says yes
it's wilson so i thought well i'm going
to go find wilson myself
and he and this person said to me do you
think he's gonna give this one up this
is he cannot and is not legally allowed
to i and i knew this but i thought well
i'm just gonna try
see what happens
so i wrote to i found wilson's email i
wrote to him and um
is the only time in my career that i
actively misrepresented myself
i felt a little bad about it but i
thought well i'm just going to do it so
i said i didn't say i was a ufo
researcher i just said i was researching
the us navy and um and his career came
up and i was very intrigued and i would
like to talk with him
so fine
sorry admiral wilson i have respect for
thomas wilson to this day i have nothing
against this man
i understand he was put in a tough
position so anyway he agreed to he gave
me his office phone number
and i called him this is still elite oh
six
and um
so he answers the phone he's very i can
almost hear him easing into this big
chair like getting ready for a nice long
interview you know
and i uh
right away i said well i'm i'm writing i
write about ufos in the u.s military to
be honest with you so sorry about the
ambush here
but there is a meeting that i know you
were part of in april 97 and uh it had
to do with e.t tech and you were with
stephen greer and edgar mitchell
he he pretended to not remember this at
first but i said look sir i've got this
confirmed i said i spoke to edgar
mitchell
i spoke to
uh stephen grier's i actually
wouldn't talk to me back then so he had
some assist some associate who said yes
great queer was there of course
obviously
um
mitchell when i asked andrew mitchell
about this i said well what did what did
mitchell what did wilson say he would do
mitchell didn't want to talk to me
because i wasn't in the crowd
mitchell said well wilson just said he
would look into it
that's all he said he would do
but i knew it happened and then this
other
scientist
who has gone unnamed
who gave me the very deep backstory
that wilson was denied access and so on
i mentioned to wilson i said look i have
this on
three sources
that uh you absolutely had this meeting
and he said oh yes i vaguely remember it
now
i was a busy man you know we were
worried about weapons of mass
destruction and all this other stuff i
didn't have time for ufo things i said
he said the only reason i even agreed to
meet with him is that someone of dr
mitchell's stature
was interested in this and i thought
well why you know why would a
moonwalking astronaut be interested in
ufos
well okay
so anyway
i said well you know the whole thing was
written about in stephen greer's book he
said
read to me what he said
so i read the passage and
in which greer talks about the meeting
and then the follow-up in which wilson's
denied access
by private contractors
and wilson said well that part is true
but everything else is poppycock and he
got he got so angry his voice got a bit
high pitched
and he uh he ended the phone call
you know i wasn't trying to be mean to
admiral wilson and
but anyway so that was my interaction
with him and
i will just say look
it was very obvious that this upset him
and
with all of these people like i i begged
the scientists who showed me those pages
way back in 06 in 2019
i
begged him
i said please let me use your name
and he's like
no
no no no
and none of them do davis won't go on
the record davis has come like this
close he really would listen to davis's
statements he is
davis has this gift for walking right up
to the line
right up to the line but not stepping
over it he goes right up there
uh
i got a no comment from hal put off and
kit green both of which are hilarious
not no comments
um
they're almost like apologies
rather than no comments about this
uh davis issued a signal or no comment
all of these people can't they cannot
talk about if any of them were to they
would they would definitely lose their
security clearances and the thing is all
of them are trying to get to the center
and this is the same for wilson
i i can't believe like how people
can be so naive about this world
all right when you retire from federal
classified service
and you go work for private industry you
don't lose your clearances you get more
clearances and they become better and
deeper
and that's because all the action's in
private industry
that's where it is
so do you think wilson doesn't have
security clearances
of course he does
they're probably better than when he was
head of the defense intelligence agency
all right
he cannot he must not ever
he can't ever cop to this he can't
i mean would destroy his career and
maybe more
so all of them are terrified
they're all terrified of breaking ranks
and um
you know it's like in the mafia
and actually one of one of these folks
in this community said to me it's like
you don't even need to sign nda's at a
certain point
all right you just know
you do
not give up information or
things will go bad for you
they just know they don't need to be
told
so that's the world
and um
you know there's some it's one thing for
a casual observer who doesn't really
understand this world
world of security clearances and
intelligence community and ufos to have
these questions i understand that but
there are some experienced journalists
out there they should know better
and uh they seem to forget this as well
but anyway um
when i talk to some of these folks
behind the scenes
i will only say every one of them says
oh yes i know that document's totally
real i know that absolutely happened
and they've known for years
and you're in a situation here and i so
i'm out here standing at times it feels
like i'm standing alone on the wilson
document that eric davis wilson notes uh
there are some other folks out there who
support them but they they're not
they're not very forthright about it and
most people just prefer to run away one
is a famous journalist who said to me
privately oh yeah i've known about this
for more than a decade as well thanks
for going out there
i'm like well do you want to go out
there and they're like no i can't
it would damage me
so um unfortunately that's where and the
irony is that this is not even a formal
government document it's private notes
written up by davis
davis gave an interview for uh the
basement office it's the new york post
uh series of interviews and he he very
nearly
even at that moment
uh
practically validated those notes
people should go back and listen to it
so no it's a fascinating story and i do
consider it the ufo leak of the century
absolutely
so that's a long that's a long backstory
there
you're getting plenty of plaudits from
the audience spud head johnny says
richard you're a top man
carl cartesian said richard dolan is
class
someone wants to know what do you think
this person freddis33 what does richard
think about bob lazar is he legit oh god
okay thanks for the feedback that's
always nice
um there's plenty more i just oh good
time to read it
there
i'll send them to you it's your email
it's it's it's fine thank you it's okay
um
as far as with lazar
i say that because
it's
there there are people who who really
they like me and then there are people
every now and then there's someone who
just hates me
and uh that doesn't like in the old days
i would be like why don't you like me my
mom thinks i'm cool and i'm like why
what what did i ever do to you but
i just realized like you know you can't
you just cannot please everybody that's
just life
i try my best i try my best to just do
good work and and just leave it at that
as far as what i think about bob lazar
um
yeah when i wrote my second volume of
ufos in the national security state
years ago i agonized over that and all i
tried to do that was back in 09 when i
published that book
uh
um
because i went into my
research with lazar i was very much on
the fence and i didn't know what i
thought and i assume everyone watching
this knows bob lazar claimed to have
seen flying flying saucers
near area 51 in a place he called s4 in
nevada
in uh
in late 1988 early 1989
on i think a total of six occasions
he was interviewed by george knapp in
1989
under a pseudonym originally dennis i
think and then comes out as bob lazar by
the i think in 1990.
so um
yes i think i believe lazar's story no
longer eric davis recently just said
lazar was full of full of
full of it and uh
i was surprised because
i know other people in that little world
connected to davis who
i know that they believe lazar story
so i was i was a bit surprised when
davis said what he did but
um
yes i think so i i don't know that
everything lazar said is true
but that doesn't mean that he's not
being
truthful there's a there's
there's one theory that i find actually
interesting
um
that could square the circle
i mean first of all you've got problems
with those are
standing friedman talked about lazar's
educational issues like he said he went
to mit he never went to mit he said he
went to caltech he never went to caltech
yeah true two things i would say about
that
one look
i remember the 1980s
i lived through the 80s in the early 90s
and
the fact was
back then
people
lied lied lied about their credentials
all the time
all the time
i mean look i don't defend the practice
i never did
but i knew a lot of people i used to
write professional resumes for job
seekers
i worked with thousands of people
and i knew like i can't do background
checks on all these folks but i knew
they were not all truthful about their
background
one woman finally she was a very nice
lady she was the hr director somewhere
she said yeah i got fired because they
found out that i didn't have this degree
that i said i had it's like it was in
the early 90s like
how many times did that happen so did
lazar lie about his education yeah
probably
um
but actually what i think he did is he
may have audited a couple of courses at
caltech or mit and
for no credit that's what it looks like
to me actually
so i'm like look am i gonna throw his
whole story out because he did that that
to me that's just ridiculous it's silly
um there are people who would say oh
well he lied about that i can't believe
anything he says okay fine fair enough
i'm not going to do that so i want to
look at the story
can it be corroborated look you talked
to george knapp who interviewed lazar
george
has interviewed about 25 other people in
addition to lazar who have had
stories
very similar or that have corroborated
various elements of what bob lazara said
that doesn't prove lazar is truthful but
it but there's a tremendous amount of
corroboration
and and keep in mind lazar was first to
go public
he wasn't the first to talk to private
researchers but he was the first to go
public he's the reason we learned about
area 51
lazar
he's the reason people knew where to go
to look for the ufos he said they fly
every wednesday over in this location
they start going like how did he know
that
he knew something
he knew something and they got arrested
the second time they went out with john
lear and a couple of other people
and he got in trouble
and he lost his job and his clearance
and whatever
but uh george you know did investigation
of lazar he did find he worked at los
alamos national labs in 1982.
he almost almost certainly did meet with
edward teller who probably got him the
job at eg
in nine you know 1988 to do what he did
um yes i think so
so um and then you talk to people who
knew lazar before oh that i i have a
friend named ron regaire who's a great
guy
ron knew lazar back back in the day
back earlier before 1989 and ron
you know
what do you say ron's like i'm telling
you man bob lazar's 100
so
lazar's got people who support him
and
i listen to that it doesn't mean that it
informs my entire judgment but
i'm not going to blow off ron rigara's
assessment i i know and like and respect
ron
um
but i believe lazar's story
fundamentally oh so here's the theory
though that that um
the late great crazy genius gordon
novelle shared with me years ago
gordon was someone who is uh obsessed
with
um
publicizing the technology of something
known as the arv
the legendary alien reproduction vehicle
that was supposedly shown
in 19 november 1988 to bradford sorensen
he's a real guy sorensen aviation
executive
uh who saw
three hovering flying saucers at
lockheed's palm uh helendale
big hanger in 1988.
he was brought in with a high level
defense official
okay
so this is a story and and according to
that story that object ran on
the vacuum
this is one year before the first paper
on zero point energy comes out
uh-huh what year was this
approximately
yes november 1988.
so it was one year before in fact the
first paper on cpe was uh co-authored by
hal put off
put-offs all over the place
zero-point energy
which has also come
you know conveniently or colloquially
described as a vacuum sometimes
so let's say let's say there's a craft
that has something to do with zero point
energy
like pretend
that that's the solution to the flying
saucer energy mystery
let's say that they can exploit
the ether or zero point like what tesla
believes in this i think and
uh
you know maybe it's true
so
if it is true and let's say we're on a
team to build a flying saucer
utilizing zpe
but we know that there's competitors out
there
and we don't want them to
be on our path they don't we don't want
them to compete with us so what might we
do we might we might psychologically
profile a guy like lazar
knowing that he could be compromised
knowing that he has this attitude where
he just didn't seem to give a [ __ ] about
certain things
and
you give him fake information
so you talk to him about
this thing running on element 115
jokingly referred to as unobtainium
because it's so impossible to get a
a stable isotope of it that that lasts
for more than a split second
we don't know how to do it
yes they were able recently like 10
years ago to create some level of
element 115 but it can't you can't get a
stable version of it
so here's lazar talking back in 1989
like saying yes i was told that it runs
on element 115 not that we manufactured
it but that was brought here by these
aliens i think is what he said
so unobtainium so if we were on the team
and we wanted to throw off our
competitors we might say we might make
up a [ __ ] and bull story about element
115
and then the competitors would say oh
crap
we can't build this let's just give up
it's not going to work
like that that was that was gordon
novell's
theory which he shared with me many
years ago and i thought oh
it's actually kind of interesting that's
intriguing maybe there's something to
that but i don't know
why was lazar told what he was
were they playing a game with him
anything is possible
anything's possible it's like a working
in you know researching in a hall of
mirrors
what is what is the real and what is the
reflection
it's difficult to sell sometimes so
that's why i think like
um
lazar's story is interesting but it's
also not
it's not a make or break thing for
ufology as a whole
fortunately
um what you heard of his story sorry
what parts of a story do you feel are
legitimate not just what he was told uh
the party where he said it corresponds
to the truth where he said i saw a craft
and went into it it was very small and i
couldn't get into it i could practically
fit in i believe that
i don't think he's making that up
i spoke to lazar about yes two weeks ago
oh and yes how about that
not for a podcast and he's a
pertinacious little fellow
and i want to desperately say pugnacious
pertinacious he's stubbornly persistent
and he
he
i want
i'm more interested in how is the strong
force associated with gravity because
he's made that claim he calls the strong
force gravity number one or gravity
number two so i'm extremely interested
in speaking with him well yeah i mean
he's lizard i met him once and um
but like you could see when you listen
to him and you watch him i've watched
him a lot and uh
he he's a real
intellectual and like a lot of these
intellectuals you said pertinacious sure
they don't all have the best social
skills
you know you're talking about people who
are analytical problem solvers and um
and they're out of the box thinkers
lazar is absolutely an out-of-the-box
type of thinker too and i think that's
why he actually was brought in so he was
a very smart smart guy
who didn't think like a normal person he
put a jet engine on his cars what got
him in the newspapers in los alamos all
those years ago that's how he met ted
teller
so he's
he's kind of like a crazy genius who
is on the quiet side
i'm not you know i i'm not going to get
a psychological profile of lazar but
he's clearly a hyper analytical kind of
a guy who
you know
is probably not he is not always easy to
deal with probably i'm just going to
guess
ben in toronto at ben in toronto wants
to know the when the former head of the
israeli space program hay mashed made
the statement last year about a galactic
federation do you think he's making that
based on some facts or his own personal
beliefs
yeah that's a great question um i think
probably a bit of both that's my hunch i
have not spoke to hayama shed um
i don't know him personally he's very
advanced in years
this is a man who he ran
israel's what was it there's i think
either their space agency
i think that's what it was and he had he
had some senior position within their
defense establishment in in general
terms
so he he was a guy like you can assume
he probably was briefed on certain
things i mean israel's active with their
space exploration
um
they've they've got unacknowledged nukes
obviously that no one ever is allowed to
talk about but they clearly have at
least 200 nuclear missiles
that they get a pass for by the global
community for some reason
but uh so they have they have a very
highly highly advanced extremely like
some of the most advanced genius
scientists in the world
who deal with space and he's one of
these people he's dealt with that so i
have to assume he's been briefed and
that he knows some things and that he
knows what he's talking about on the
other hand
um
when we talked about the galactic
federation first of all when we talked
about donald trump probably knowing
about it
that could be absolutely like he might
have just known for real uh
would surprise me if donald trump didn't
know something about this but when he
starts talking about the galactic
federation this is something that you've
here in fact in the new eight we talked
about the new age community a little
while ago like this is a big thing with
the new age ufo community the galactic
federation sometimes the galactic
federation of light
and uh from my part
maybe i'm does this have to do with the
pleiades the pleiades some galactic
sometimes they're brought into it what
is it called the pleiades right the
pleiadians yeah i heard of this yeah
they get they get roped in sometimes yes
sometimes no there's different groups
supposedly that are involved and i don't
know how anyone really knows the truth
on this to be honest with you but
but um
maybe i'm the one who's wrong maybe
maybe there is a galactic federation and
i just
but i don't personally believe that
there is
so when i hear hayam i should talk about
this i think
he's probably working off of
you know people in the ufo community
edgar mitchell was the same way
astronaut edgar mitchell i mean i i knew
i wasn't close friends with him but he
he wrote endorsements from my first
three or four books
i was very grateful to him and he and i
talked with him and
he he clearly knew certain things but he
was also working
with researchers in the community and
his own beliefs and i think that's
probably the case with
with mr eschat so
i i suspect it's a combination of both
and then you know the other thing is
when you get when you get to that age
and i am i
i've read his statements
he struck me as someone who is still
very much in command of his faculty so
don't i don't want to be misunderstood
here
but i also will say when someone gets to
a certain age they either stop giving a
damn and they just talk and that could
very well be the case with him
but it also can happen
i mean i saw this in my with my own
father before he died
um
the stories change
the stories change my dad was a new york
city cop and uh i knew
all of i knew all the stories
they changed around what age they
changed precipitously he died at the age
of 79 two months a month before he
turned 80.
and uh i would say in the last
for him the last two years
he would tell me it always goes back to
brooklyn and dealing with the gangs you
know that was like his glory ears and um
i remember saying to him hey that's not
how that story went down he says what
are you talking about richie i was
always richie to him
that's what it was and i'm like no
not really i wasn't going to argue with
my dad but i knew the stories changed so
things do happen and cognitive things
happen to people get older some
sometimes and it can happen at different
ages with my dad it was
after he turned 75
maybe 76
and i don't know that that's the case
with mr i should i don't know but but i
do say like when you deal with very
elderly witnesses
i'm i'm just sorry but you have to keep
that in mind you got to keep in mind the
possibility of cognitive decline and
stories changing and it can happen and
it has happened
sometimes not always
atwack sublime whose name is adam
langley wants to know
do you know anything
referring to the past of bob lazar
calling aliens or aliens calling us
containers oh
i love these questions yes yes yes
so lazar said when he before he actually
went
into s4
that his first
day of briefing actually consisted of
him being brought to a room and having
to read materials
and
and so these materials
talked
about these alien beings to
a significant extent
and in that briefing
lazar
read
that the beings
i think it was the aliens referred to us
as containers
now i don't i don't think that in
lazar's reading or in his
statement about his reading let's say
that he ever actually really explained
what he thought that meant
i mean i think it's an obvious thing to
to think what it could mean you know
containers for what for your soul
for whatever that
element of you that might survive the
death of the body if such a thing is
possible i personally believe that that
is possible
my own opinion at this point in my life
and
and that the body would be the container
for the soul
so i think that's
probably how i would answer that
this question comes from tyler cates
if angels landed
okay forget about angels so if someone
landed and threatened to murder you if
you don't prove the existence of a alien
spacecraft how would you convince them
wait wait wait uh but stalking let's say
someone puts a gun ahead and says
convince me puts a gun to your head says
convince me aliens exist
or the existence of alien spacecraft
what would you do well what i would do
is i would say put the goddamn gun down
first of all let's talk
sorry i shouldn't use the language
um
well i was what i've said for years
all right
i'm not gonna prove to you that aliens
are here what i will prove
is that for
75 years the united states government
has covered up
its
opinion that ufos are real
based on military declassified documents
and what i was what i would say i could
prove is that there have been encounters
with ufos
that look like flying saucers by the
united states military
that i think i could prove
i mean if if you want to accept
declassified government documents as
legitimate forms of evidence which i
think if you're not going to accept that
then i don't know how to have a
conversation with someone so you've got
documents that come out of the national
archives through foia
and um
and they show time and again one i mean
this is what i wrote about in my two
volumes of ufos in the national security
state it was the primary
thing that i tried to do is to highlight
what the foia record tells us
which is that you have case after case
after case after case of u.s jets u.s
military personnel encountering
ufos
doing extraordinary things
and then then you learn oh it's not just
the americans
this happens in
the belgian uranium mine in 1952 it
happened countless times over the soviet
union when when the soviet union was
cracking apart in the late 1980s guess
what information came out there too
that was that was their moment that's
when the window was open and we learned
about kgb files their their so-called
blue folder i think it was called and we
learned about uh the unbelievable july
28 1989 case over uh kapustan yar that's
their rocket facility that's their
equivalent of wife's hands
unbelievable case
astonishing
or march of 1990 uh you know west of
moscow where you have more engagements
by soviet jet fighters you have soviet
generals describing the object doing s
maneuvers both vertically and
horizontally
and uh and more and more i mean so
there's
what i could say is i could prove
that there's a phenomenon
that again i just would say it's not
supposed to exist but it does
now
that's the start of the conversation
where does that conversation end does
that mean
we're building we've got a secret
breakaway civilization
that's that's a phrase i coined many
years ago to describe a super advanced
secret uh technological society that's
got their own scientific breakthroughs
that they keep classified and you're not
allowed to have it and so forth and have
they did they invent flying saucers
secretly
you know some years ago is that what's
happening i don't know maybe
you could speculate about that
is it is it that the nazis back in world
war ii actually were developing this and
we brought those scientists over through
paperclip and we
developed it there
that's an argument
whatever the answer or is it aliens
or is it something else like whatever
the answer is it's interesting i mean
you have people should acknowledge
that's a damned interesting thing to you
know look into
but
but that's where you start
and so that's what i would i would be
confident to say now does it mean it's
aliens well i mean frankly when you look
at the different hypotheses
you know like nazi tech
developed secretly in the u.s okay maybe
or some other kind of uh earth-based
scenario all of those are possible but
to me when i've looked at them all
i see all those as actually less
likely
than another non-human civilization
that's my own
that's my own opinion i think
combined with the evidence
let's say testimony might be a better
word
from
large numbers of people who have
encountered what they are convinced are
non-human entities
often and frequently in connection with
these ufos
so when i see when i put all of that
together
i think
that's my favorite hypothesis
that's the one that makes the most sense
to me that there
there are other beings they don't come
from here
wherever they come from i don't i don't
know where they come from and i can't
sure as hell can't prove it
and i would be a fool to try
so
if i if i couldn't prove those aliens
and they would probably would pull the
trigger and i'd be dead so i couldn't i
don't know if i would
want to try to prove
that
ufos are aliens
i i don't think that's the smart way to
go i think what you want to do is you
look at the evidence of what we have
available
and that's the thing like most people
don't look at the evidence
they just don't
they don't familiarize themselves with
it
so you look at the evidence and then you
come up with your best hypotheses
and there's room for you know good faith
disagreements
i totally believe that
i get corrected i have a membership
website richard on members.com there are
people who belong to my site they're way
smarter than me
i learn from them all the time they have
they have different opinions sometimes
than i do and i i can tell you i always
make sure to listen carefully to them
because there's so much more that i
still can learn
on the topic of potential other beings
do you think that we can communicate
with them through dmt or psychedelics do
you think that when people claim to have
encountered other entities that this may
be related to this phenomenon of
alien life ufos yeah possible
i've never done dmt i've not done an
ayahuasca journey
sorry
most i've done is a little bit of pot
that's the farthest i've ever gone down
the road of hallucinogenics anything
i don't think that counts
so there are people who've done
ayahuasca journeys and they talk about
um
encountering entities
often lizard-like reptilian-type
entities and apparently at least
anecdotally
um
they will
seem to describe a lot of consistency
and and they and i do know like in the
dmt community there's lots of discussion
what's going on here is this all
internal reality or is this
have we opened a doorway to
an actual genuine reality that is you
know beyond the doors of perception
basically that we
we can access through the right
state of being state of mind or chemical
balance or whatever and i know they
discuss this and i think a lot of them
believe that they're actually
encountering something genuine something
real
could be that
to me that's
i haven't done that and i don't know how
to uh relate to it in my own internal
experience you know because i haven't
had it done i haven't done it
but um
yeah i wouldn't say no i i would i would
say it's possible that there's a
connection there to some extent
keep in mind though
there's a definite physical nature to a
good portion of the ufo phenomenon
you've got countless ground trace
evidence
you've had laboratory analyses done
frequently
of uh materials where ufos like affected
the plant life
where it landed things like this like
um it was a good french case from
january 1980
that uh
what the hell was it called provencal
case that um
chuck filet wrote about this they had a
lot of scientific
examination done of the
grass and of the trees and
anomalous things like so there's a
physical nature to the ufo sub
phenomenon
but is it possible that there is a
dimensional connection somehow yes
totally possible i don't know
oliver drow wants to know
please ask him what he thinks of project
galileo led by avi loeb
will it work
oh yeah um
i'm going to pass because i i know of it
but i don't and i know avilobe is
engaged in um
in doing this project but i i'm going to
just plead ignorance because i don't
know all the details that obvi loeb is
planning to do
relating to it so i apologize i just i'm
not on top of that one
and for those of you interested in
navilope we interviewed him on this
channel you can check the description
and it'll be there
i just want to say this i i don't want
to i have nothing to say against avilube
not nothing at all however
uh it's very obvious that he's he's not
a ufo expert not that everyone has to be
i'm very i'm pleased that he's
open enough about the ufo subject or at
least
the possibility that we're being visited
uh that
you know that's a good thing
but um i've not really gotten the sense
that he really knows
deep
that he has deep information about this
subject but i'm glad that he's taking an
active role into the extent that he
engages in positive discourse i think us
to the better
philip koshy wants to know ross
colthardt mainstream muscle
yes cole hart investigative reporter
from the 60 minutes has written a book
that among other things has gotten a
deathbed confession talking about a
black budget reverse engineering process
is richard aware of this
i have to download the book i know it
just came out i know i know about ross
i've had some communications with him
behind the scenes i knew about the work
he's doing
uh to sum to a limited extent not not to
not to any kind of detailed
i was not privy to it most of his
research i've heard about it a little
bit
from one intermediary who knew quite a
lot about what was going on
um i can't comment on the deathbed
confession i do know this i mean ross is
a very smart and good journalist
so i'm looking forward to reading his
book his book
very much so
this question i've asked to both jeremy
corbell and luis elizondo it's from
lonesome space cowboy the username is
from reddit he wants to know if the
world could see what you have seen
i'm sure some of what you've seen you
can't talk about so if the world saw it
how would the world react what would the
next week look like
i don't know
you know i've been surprised by the
like we've had a series of
shall we say revelations in the last
several years
you know we have we have an admission by
the united states navy that they
encounter ufos for god's sake
and no one's known a thing
no reaction
um
i i would have thought you know i wrote
a book 10 years ago that dealt with
these issues 12 years ago um
what would happen if there was a
government admission that ufo's are real
i thought well it could cause an
avalanche effect and
that has not yet happened
now what we're having is kind of a drip
drip drip of information
so
so is it because it's like the frog
being boiled or it's our apathy
a lot of it's through much much greater
propaganda control over our media i mean
back then you know the legacy media was
totally controlled yes but big tech uh
had not yet assumed full control over
facebook and youtube and twitter and all
that those are still areas where there
was genuine freedom
and that's not the case anymore
you try to type in ufo on youtube
and you will get nothing but corporate
cnn bbc fox cnn msnbc come on
and sometimes with like low view counts
they're obviously they cheat on the
algorithm and everything is corporate
so it's it's becoming more and more
difficult
um and
but anyway like if the world somehow
magically knew
everything that i know
yeah i think i think the ufo cover-up
would there there would be a lot of
angry people i guess i would put it that
way there'd be a lot of people who
who would
actually would demand
from their government
for
an investigation into ufos problem that
they would run into
because this is also what i know now
is that
i don't think that there's a single
central government repository where the
ufo
secrets being held
i think i think it's outside the purview
of the u.s government i think all the us
government does is surprise security
detail for the secret on behalf of of um
corporate and financial power
that actually
has the information
and who those guys are i don't
all i can do is guess
but i think some of them probably go to
davos every now and then they may go to
bilderberg meetings like that crowd yes
i think some of those people probably
are some of those individuals
um and that all that the us military now
does is um basically serve as their
security force
they prevent outsiders from getting in
they prevent taxpayers from learning
about the program they even prevent
not just congress congress has no access
to this but they prevent
senior dod officials from having access
you know access to those programs is
limited to
i don't i don't know if
any one person in the department of
defense actually
has access to some of these programs
officially speaking
the people organizing sap special
operations special special access
program up oversight committee
i think officially it's like
three or four people
who
theoretically have access to those files
but that doesn't mean that they get into
those files it doesn't mean they get
into the programs it just means that
they in theory have oversight access
nobody else to my knowledge
if the president demanded i mean could
the president
i don't know i mean all we have are
stories about that
i have one story about bill clinton from
the late 90s some a scientist that i
know actually met with clinton had him
for five minutes at an event
he said i waited for my moment
they had a couple of things in common
they talked about and the
this guy
uh he led into ufos by by thanking him
for liberalizing the freedom of
information laws to some extent that at
that time made it a little bit easier
for people to do fire requests
and then and then he somehow gently
brought up the ufo question to clinton
and according to this man
who i believe
clinton said uh something to the effect
of yeah i'm sorry there's not much i can
do about that i wish i could do more
about that but my hands are tied
and that's all clinton said apparently
so that
and you think about it like how much can
a u.s president
actually even do
really
i mean does anyone think that u.s
presidents are really actually elected
they're selected they're not elected
it's been the way for generations
you've got a very very tightly
controlled system there
and i
i just don't even donald trump who seems
to be an anomaly
trump is a definite anomaly absolutely
trump is as much of an anomaly
um maybe even more of an anomaly than
kennedy was kennedy kennedy i would say
before trump was the last president who
actually thought he was president
that's why they killed him
kennedy actually thought
i'm gonna
i'm gonna decapitate the cia which he
tried to do
uh i'm gonna i'm gonna print non-federal
reserve money
four billion dollars which i mean even
in 1963 was not going to make or break
but it was the beginning
uh
and you know
apparently in october of 1963
talk privately about pulling u.s out of
vietnam after he got reelected another
bad move kennedy
and also yes according to a november
11th memo from 1963 11 days before he
was killed
talked about authorizing or ordering the
cia to cooperate
more with the soviet union on the matter
of ufos it's like good grief this guy
he was like murdered in an agatha
christie murder mystery it's like where
everyone's got a motive like there's so
many reasons that right the cabal
you know plus he's trying to take out
the mafia how dare he he got elected
yeah man that takes such courage
you know they brought out the cemetery
vote for kennedy he should not have won
illinois whatever you think about nixon
and kennedy kennedy should have lost
illinois he should have lost the
election but he won because he had the
mob
so kennedy goes in there and he starts
pissing off everyone and they take him
out so then then for another
how many 40
almost 50 years right
every subsequent american president
knows
you don't screw with these people
they will take you down absolutely
then comes trump
out of nowhere
you got a republican
campaigning in south carolina in 2016
dishing out against the war in iraq
no republican ever did that how dare he
and he did it
he's a republican doing ralph nader's
old gig in the 90s talking against
globalization that's something that the
liberals used to do
ralph nader remember nader in the late
90s like we're going to lose jobs
through
these trade deals with china nader said
this
on behalf of working-class people and in
the democratic party kicked them out
basically they didn't want anything to
do with them but he was doing it from
the left and then that whole thing
failed and then 20 years later guy does
it from the right
like people were shocked
and then he gets elected
i remember a week before that election
julian assange from his exile said trump
won't be allowed to be elected
and i think everyone thought that
i think everyone believed that
i mean obviously the establishment fix
was in for hillary that was
obvious to anyone with half a brain
right
i mean never in the history of american
media had you seen an onslaught against
one person that intent like you
are free not to like the guy he's a
trash talker he's in new york as a new
yorker i grew up with everyone i grew up
with talk like that the men and the
women the boys and the girls they all
talk like that so that didn't that the
language never offended me i mean it's
maybe unpresidential but that's his
style
what i found interesting about him was
his geopolitics and his global politics
i mean what the reason trump had to be
taken out
frank honestly there's only one it's not
because he was a bad person not because
he was racist not sexist none of that
ridiculous nonsense
he got taken out because he dared to
oppose the two pillars
of american global policy which are
which you must never do
and that is
international empire neoconservative
empire the neocon thing
and globalization
you can you never you cannot oppose that
are you kidding me
and he went out as a candidate and
opposed both of them
you know i would think it was chuck
schumer right after trump got elected
he's on with amy goodman of democracy
now now
right
and
and
schumer he's talking about trumpet and
and the cia and he says oh my god don't
take on the cio cia they'll find six
ways till sunday to take you down
and of course amy goodman by this point
i mean she did not ask a single
follow-up question but like obviously
trump had the entire intelligence
establishment after him
he went against you cannot talk against
the wars now he ended up being
surrounded by a lot of the same people
that would have surrounded hillary you
know the same neo bloodthirsty neocons
so um his international policy wasn't
much different than what you would have
gotten with any of the others
uh he was a little less belligerent in
the middle east
that's for sure
uh hillary clinton would have started a
major war in syria and she actually
talked about it so she was going to
escalate all that
and trump didn't do that so that's to
his credit i got to say
but otherwise he was pretty bellicose
uh
but he did stick to his guns and
globalization
and you know protect the borders and all
that so that's just unacceptable you
cannot do that so was he allowed in on
the ufo secret i think that's what
you're asking and
um i mean i don't know
i think
it's obvious that the guy was interested
in it
you know in the last year of his
presidency he made a number of
statements
don jr
talking to him and i think june of 2020
about this
he's asking his dad about roswell
you know trump trump is a guy who
was very friendly to alternative media
in the years prior to his candidacy so
um
he's a nephew of an fbi agent who raided
tesla's home after tesla died in 1943
i got to think trump knew knows
some things that are very interesting
uh whether he was able to get a formal
briefing on this
that's a great question i wish i knew
the answer and i just do not
don't know i don't want to start you on
conspiracies but what occurs to me right
now is i want to know your thoughts
if you can briefly on covet is covid
related to alien phenomenon in some way
whether through vaccinations or through
the spreading of the disease okay then
also
look i don't i don't want to get i've
heard everything and i've heard them
from people much smarter than me
and they're and i've heard all different
opinions from people who are much
smarter than me
and i just don't know what i think i
want to think about that right now i
will say that the response to covet has
been
criminal and draconian
and anti-human
and i personally
do not believe in the lockdowns i've
never believed in the lockdowns i don't
believe in destroying your society by
economic suicide by
running you know 50 percent of the
businesses in america that have closed
it probably never going to reopen
and
i think the psychological damage to
especially young people with the masking
and the distancing i think is criminal
and i think the day will come
maybe one day when we get some sanity
back in our world when we look back
at
the criminality
against people in this world by by
treating the way we've treated them and
i think that the response to covet has
has
sped up
our
descent
into what i've often been calling the
fourth stage of humanity which i wrote
about in my last book the alien agendas
and
simply speaking i think
what we're moving into is a new
fundamental form of human organization
in which
you know you look at all the technology
we've got so you got
coming ai
you know singularity if that's if that's
even the word we want to use for it
sometimes that's not the best word but
anyway
very advanced strong ai generative ai
that can think for itself
um
genetic monop modification crispr
technology you know all that designer
babies um
5g 6g
24 7 surveillance to smart devices that
will give you zero privacy and you'll
have none for the rest of all time and
your grandchildren won't have any so
we're going to turn humanity into big
giant anthill that's really what i think
is happening i really believe that
like you know think of china's social
credit system and with all you know if
you jaywalk there you that can that that
dings you on your on your ability
sometimes to get a loan
much less if you speak out against the
government and they facial wreck
everyone and they probably voice wreck
everyone there so they're we're probably
a decade behind
realistically we're already partially
there like through big tip we don't have
formal implementation yet
of a social credit system but it's it's
coming
that's coming so maybe 10 years down the
road but anyway so we're doing all of
this in covid there was the lockdown
response to covid the draconian legal
measure that had been taken
against people
for this
are criminally anti-human
and they are
accelerating
this is my opinion
i'm sure people are out there saying
fu
to what i'm saying
but this is my opinion and i believe
that it's it's a criminally anti-human
global
coordinated
effort
to break
this society in the form that it has
been
and to create a new society yeah that's
what i think
that's what i believe so whether it's by
design as a pandemic or not you know
my opinion has always been that it
probably escaped from the wuhan lab i
thought that right out of the gate and
for over a year of course that was
almost it was almost illegal even to say
that publicly you say that publicly they
take you down
and then jon stewart says it on colbert
and suddenly like it's okay to say it
now but the fact is that yes it always
seemed logical how could it not be
logical
they're working on the exact virus right
there
their patents on coronavirus like it's
not an unknown thing
but anyway um whether it was
intentionally released or not i i don't
i don't know and i can't know
it could have accidentally gotten out
sure
accidents do happen hey elvis costello
told us that many years ago
all right bad joke but anyway i think it
could have happened and um
accidentally it could have been an
accidental leak could have been an
intentional leak i don't know
but i think it probably came out of a
lap
okay last question and then while you're
answering i'm going to quickly turn off
my video on audio but so my wife can go
in the background and leave and then
i'll turn it right back on she's just
been
waiting there for quite some time very
painful you obviously have a wonderful
life yeah i do
okay victor wag asks suppose you had
access to technology that could put 35
million
truck drivers out of work virtually
overnight
do you release the tech or slow drip the
tech
while keeping an eye on the environment
wow what an awesome question because
that's actually going to happen truck
driving is the biggest especially for
non-university educated people
um
driving i think is the largest
occupation
definitely for men but there's a lot of
women out there too now who are drivers
and
with uh
you know google
algorithms and like self-driving cars
i think that tech exists i mean i know
that
there are imperfections in it and i
could also like for right now
you try driving an 18-wheeler i mean i
don't i don't drive an 18-wheeler and i
don't pretend i think didn't joe biden
say he drove an 18-wheeler is that true
but anyway
i've driven some large vehicles
like big a big u-haul
on highways and bad weather
on twisty roads and i'll tell you man
that's like that's crazy
i cannot imagine an algorithm yet
maybe i'm wrong maybe i'm not
underestimating the algos
but
it's a tricky thing to entrust them with
that
yet
however
i do think it's going to be possible
to um
to develop those algorithms and
implement them
and if it were my power to do so oh my
god i would go as slow as i possibly
could go
that's me maybe that you know
that might be the wrong decision
militarily or in terms of economics but
it's like the race for 5g
i'm not a fan of it
i i don't want to see 5g in this world
i'm not a fan i think we're at a point
now in a society where the tech we're
serving the technology rather than the
rivers we're organizing our society
around the technology rather than using
tech to improve our society and our
lives that's what i think's happening
and that's why i
um so when you have um
you know the development of 5g like this
is a race this is an arms race it has
military implications significant
military implications so the us and
china and russia and the european
nations like there they have to develop
this as soon as possible from there from
a purely military communications point
of view they've got to develop 5g and
also
pardon me
excuse me from an economic point of view
there are
major
economic implications
to this that could be very beneficial to
you if you develop the tech the problem
is
uh
well the problem is what what happens to
society when you have
5g capabilities and it's not just uh
you're going to be in your phone but
it'll be in your lamp and it'll be in
your toilet it'll be in your
refrigerator it'll be in your toaster
like it'll be in everything it'll be in
your ceiling fan and
like that's happening
and
and what will that do to human society
what will it do to human psychology
bad things
very bad things that's what it's going
to do so so we're going to pay a big
price
a bad price
for the roll out of this tech
very bad price but but how do you stop
it how do you slow it down
and i i mean look i'm gonna tell you i
don't know how to slow it down i don't
have that answer and it's the same with
what the question was
uh driving algorithms or driving
capabilities that can replace 35 million
truck drivers i thought is that the
number i thought it was even more than
that but whatever
um
you know economists call this the
robo-apocalypse
that's terminator coming not to kill you
just to take your job
that's the world we're moving toward
these are mainstream economists this is
not fringe stuff here this is what they
standard university economists they all
seem to believe it's coming
and
not just with manual labor anymore but
increasingly intellectual lamer
what's going to happen in a world where
you've got
a structural unemployment that may be 30
percent of the human population or more
what do you do with these people
well i think one thing you do is you
make drugs fully legal and available or
illegal drugs available so they so
they're whacked out on drugs you may let
them get nice and obese they sit in
front of their screen and they can't do
anything and you feed them with toxic
garbage food and you give them garbage
news and propaganda to beat over their
head with
and you immerse them in a you know
virtual reality and augmented reality
gaming
you know give them something to do so
they're not going to be a problem
the restless mob that's what you want to
avoid
maybe you try to do depopulation if
that's feasible i don't know how
feasible that is
but you you control the population more
and more through active psychological
measures and then soon they're going to
have ai of course in facebook and social
media that will be able to really manage
your psychology even better than now
like they the the capabilities for this
are just
i'm it terrifies me
to even think about where we're going
with all that
honestly
and i wish i had better answers for how
to deal with it the only thing i could
say to people
is look
we have at all costs we must maintain
that which makes us
human
that means all of our warts and all all
the
awful things about us and all the good
things about us don't don't desire to be
a trans human
freaking perfect robot like people like
kurzweil talk about i think that's just
anti-human dangerous horrible terrible
vision for humanity
maybe it's inevitable
what are some of these human qualities
we should preserve
emotion
anger
compassion
love
all of it
all things that make us what we are
curiosity
bravery
bravery for sure
we're developing a society that's moving
us against all of it look how we're
raising kids these days kids aren't even
allowed to play
they're not allowed to play
when i was a kid growing up in the olden
times prehistoric days of the 1970s i
was probably outside on my bike miles
from home at age ten or nine
doing all kinds of crazy things
getting into fights getting out of
fights playing playing pickup football
games with guys i didn't know who half
these guys were miles from my house
dealing with people that you learn like
they don't oh that guy doesn't like me
well that's what you learn when you're
growing up like that's what you learn
and that's how you that's how you become
strong psychologically we don't do that
to kids anymore
everyone set up for play dates and
they're kept in the house kids don't
have free time anymore and they don't
have it in school either
i remember having recess in my school 45
minutes every day outside when the
weather was good which was many days
field so large no adult could monitor
all of that are you kidding fights
galore bad bad language everywhere
but cooperation as well stories kids
just dealing with kids so that's
we need a psychologically healthy
upbringing for young people that's
number one
and that's the opposite of what we're
doing
opposite
safety first and everything in our
society must be safe let's just bubble
wrap the whole population well that's
what we're doing i think
so i think it's a real tragedy i think
it's a real tragedy and so we need to
maintain humanity
that's our humanity and for the people
who want to be like kurzweil's
frankensteinian fantasy like
you're going to have an iq of 200 or 300
and um
you'll live for 500 years you know the
nanobots will course through your blood
and keep you alive forever like who the
hell wants to do that that's a great way
to lose your mind
do you honestly think that a person
could live for 300 years and not become
insane
like seriously think about that
i bet it's impossible i bet you'd lose
your sanity
at a certain point i just think so
or other bad things would happen
psychologically and i don't want to
consider i just think we're not designed
for that
i think we're designed to live
grow
fight the good fight however we do
you learn what you learn you reproduce
you have a new generation you die
that's what we do
that's what the human condition is
what do the ancient philosophers always
say we're between the angels and the
beasts
right
you know we're we have consciousness
that the beasts of the field don't have
but are we the angels well no
in every every
wise person of the past
you read greek greek tragedy
aeschylus
one of my faves
what do they all talk about
hubris
that certain pride that human beings
have when they put themselves at the
level of the gods
and what do the gods do when you get
there they smack you down man
there's a wisdom there we're not at the
level of the gods
and it's not our place but you got these
crazy people there's a 1960s futurist
named gerald feinberg he wrote a book
about it was basically the prototype for
what kurzweil and and the rest are onto
all that transhumanist future
no one's satisfied with being a human
being
you know we want to be like the aliens
we want to we want to transcend
we want to be like
in a ramp up to 2012
i remember people talking about
ascension
like what do you don't like being that's
a death wish that's a death wish
like die and go to heaven well what
about just like living here
and struggling
and developing
you develop wisdom through suffering
you suffer into the truth that's what
aeschylus wrote you suffer into the
truth that's what we do there's no
shortcut
there's no shortcut into that
so
so be a human being don't deny it
embrace it
love it
you can love it and hate it at the same
time
yes because we're a massive
contradiction so
so that's what i mean by preserving our
humanity and
you know
preserving
[Music]
family structures that make us what we
are
preserving loving relationships which
make us which make our lives worth
living
why do you want to live without love why
would you want to live without
the connection to your family the people
who are the most important and yet we
destroy our families all the time
families just get blown up every day
every year
people move they move around the world
they don't
no i just don't i don't think that's
right i think there's there's something
unhealthy about it
so we we transform our world in this
last 150 years basically
in a way that is yes anti-human
and we're paying a price psychologically
more and
more
thank you so much
yeah thank you this is fun sort of
[Laughter]
i don't mean to get into a dark place
there but look this is just what i think
sometimes
but um
i wouldn't change it for the world
i wouldn't change the difficulties we
have for anything
i feel like this is our adventure
so let's
let's ride it let's embrace it
let's learn everything we can from it
and you know you just struggle and you
be the best you can be
there's nothing else you can do
speaking of the best
who are some of the most credible people
in this ufo
seen either
people who are eyewitnesses or
researchers themselves this question
comes from paul walsh and essentially i
want to know the same but with regard to
physics
well i'm glad you talked with eric davis
because i i mean
i'm not a physicist and i'm not
qualified to comment but i mean i listen
to davis and i think this man's
i don't know about being a genius but
he's super brilliant and he and he knows
he knows things
davis has been briefed into things he
knows a lot so anything you can pry out
of him is worth prying out
uh same with hal put off
hal talks much less in davis
but in terms of research well people in
the field travis walton who came up i
think earlier in the conversation i have
nothing but admiration for travis
great i'm speaking with him next week
i've known him many years i did a
i drove across a state of state of
pennsylvania with him once it was a six
hour plus drive
but i've hung out with travis on many
many many many occasions and um
i have only have the best regard for him
personally and i
there's no doubt in my mind that he's a
completely truthful man none none at all
in terms of researchers
you always want to hear what linda
moulton howe has to say whether you
agree with her or not
linda to me is a lion
i adore her and i respect her
um i haven't always agreed with
everything that has come out of her
research
but you know what like i don't i don't
have to agree with someone 100 of the
time to find them worthwhile
i don't do that so if someone's wrong
about something once in a while well you
know then they're wrong
but i have a very high regard for linda
um
i'm a fan of nick redfern
nix people don't know nick as well as
they should nick's a very prolific
author
i respect his last name
fern
red fern
um he's a british move to the u.s
nick's written a lot of books
i have disagreed with some of his theses
over the years but overall i have mad
respect for his
integrity as a researcher i really like
him
um
who else there's a lot of researchers
who will have good things to say i'm
interested in ross cohart so i'm glad
someone mentioned ross
i don't know if he's a genuine ufo
researcher or just a damn good
journalist who got into the ufo field
however you look at it but he's worth
listening to
um
how do i identify misinformation
in this field
or how does one identify so this can
this dr kickass 77 wants to know this i
want to know it personally
when i wrote uh ufos for the 21st
century mind that was 20
13 2014 i think
um i had one section on the development
of ufology and i spent
back then a few pages on things that you
could do as an armchair researcher
i think overall they're still valuable
um
back then reverse image searches were
kind of a new thing and i i talked i
wrote about i was like look
there's ways that you can do your own
research
i talked about that or very similar like
sometimes if someone has a photograph
for example that's an alleged this or
that or whatever like search it find out
what you want to do with any story is
look for the origin
where is the first instance of this
claim originating ever
like you want to do that all the time
and sometimes that's easy and sometimes
it's difficult sometimes you can figure
that out in 10 minutes of searching
sometimes it might take weeks or you
never even get the answer but you try
you've got to always find out where did
this thing start
you have to do that
so any claim
and
and then you know just basic rules like
you want
you follow certain protocols
so when someone makes
a claim a statement
depends on the information you ask
yourself can this
is has this information been thoroughly
debunked anywhere
you start with that
and then when if it has been allegedly
debunked you got to check the debunker
like are they really legit or are they
just playing their own little game
like for example
when when uh
ttsa elizondo and melon
facilitated the release of those three
ufo videos at the end of 2017 early 2018
so you have the tic tac video you get
the go fast video and the
uh the gimbal ufo video those are three
that came out
so there was a whole discussion over a
meta bunk run by uh mick west
and they were debunking these they were
saying this is a hoax like the the video
is real but the audio's hoaxed
and i'm like no that actually turned out
to be complete nonsense
so just because medibunk may have their
own opinion doesn't mean even they're
legit or true
they can have their own agendas
so
but what you do is you
when any information comes out you ask
yourself what is the origin
uh
how can this be corroborated or not if
there's no way to corroborate it
whatsoever then you got to be careful
like then don't throw all of your energy
into it
you know be careful
qualify what you know
there's a lot of gray baskets as stan
friedman said there's a lot of stuff in
that gray basket and you better be you
got to learn to be comfortable with
uncertainty
in this field that's the name of a great
zen book it's one of my favorite books
on that subject zen but it's a good rule
for life
you better be comfortable with
uncertainty
and so
know what you know know what you can
prove
construct your
architecture around what you can be
cartesian
know what's know what you know
construct
a solid edifice
around what is known
and around things that you don't know
well then you
you do your best and you make qualified
assessments to the best of your ability
that's it
i say that's it like that's easy but
it's
not easy but that's
that's all that i know how to do
there's a snarky comment here from e
alistar stan who says interesting
interview but i don't buy any of these
ufo stories how is it that many people
managed to clearly video
cell ass bins
meteor some meteor
a once in a 100 year event but somehow
no one manages to get a clear photo or
video of ufos occam's razor says dot dot
so how do you respond to a comment like
that
well i mean look i i don't have the time
to walk him through kindergarten level
ufology it's clear that he hasn't gone
through it
it's obvious from the comment
so study the military declassified
documents first before you embarrass
yourself
with snarky comments
honestly
don't walk into a subject that you know
nothing about and act like you actually
know
everything like why do that
so have enough humility
to recognize that you don't know all the
evidence
because otherwise you wouldn't say what
you did
to me you know
as i said to you earlier
uh the evidence doesn't suggest or hint
the evidence proves one thing
that the united states military has
encountered
genuine ufos
and i say this through an analysis of
declassified united states military
documents
there's not just five or ten there's
hundreds of them
they're good documents they're real
documents
it doesn't prove that these are alien it
proves that there's something there's
trouble in paradise
so let's just look at that and puzzle it
out
and ask ourselves what could these
things be could they be
misidentifications well yeah maybe they
could be but let's look into it i've
looked i've tried to look into it and i
don't think that's the answer
not at least for all of them
no not at all
not even for most of those good those
good documents i don't think
uh one one person asked earlier like
some good documented cases there's one
it's called the rb47 case from
1957.
there's another military case so this is
um so you haven't even an aywax aircraft
this is a military aircraft it's like
electronic counter measures electronic
so they're doing a
mission across the southeastern
united states i can't remember exactly
what states i think
alabama oklahoma
and they encounter
for
i think it is 29
minutes
with their instrumentation
uh an incredible series
of encounters
with an object that just i think
literally flew circles around their
aircraft
it really happened it's a real case and
it came through
uh
military conversations i can't remember
how that one actually came out but it's
no one's argued that it happened
so i would say i didn't i didn't mean to
sound mean to the individual who made
the comment look
i apologize if i came across as
ungenerous to you
but the thing is
um
i have found over and over again
that when i encounter people with
scientific background brilliant people
who know their disciplines extremely
well
they walk into ufos
as if they know
what they are talking about and in
reality is they vastly underestimate
the
the depth and breadth of the evidence
that the ufo phenomenon provides
that's the
ultimate thing that i think is missing
cool thank you richard i appreciate that
happy to do it
yeah i think i was a little mean in my
response so i'm sorry if i was
no that's well
essentially what the person is getting
at at least what i'm interpreting the
person to be getting at is
there's clear photos of various
phenomena but when it comes to the ufo
at least even actually there are some
decent photographs there's there's some
photographs that are not bad that have
not in my opinion really been debunked
i i would i wouldn't go back to the 1950
mcminnville oregon photographs
taken by paul trent
they made the cover of what was it life
or true magazine at the time
[Music]
though there was a case made in the late
70s that these were fakes
uh i don't i don't think so at all i
when you look into the backstory of that
i don't think so not the least those are
real uh whatever they were they look it
looks like a flying saucer flew over
their property and flew away
uh but there's many many others there is
one
from the same year in ruin france of a
similar object it's not the greatest
photographed i admit the greatest
photograph but i
i think it's legit uh there's one i
found from
there's a lot of these that happen
without the photographer realizing
there's one from 1981
in uh i think on vancouver island taken
by a lady named hannah mcroberts
and she was on vacation with her family
she takes a picture of a mountain
pardon me and um
they developed this is the days of
photographic negatives
are you googling the picture to go take
a look at it it's an interesting shot
um
this is i know 1981 1981 i think it's
october 1981
hannah mcroberts
and this photograph and the negative
were available for analysis remember
this is pre-digital photography uh dr
richard haynes of uh jpl of the home of
the ames laboratory associated with jpl
uh undertook a very thorough
photographic analysis of this did
detailed interviews of the family as
well
i think that photograph checks out hell
of a picture
what what is that object there
so no it's not true to say that there
are no decent ufo pictures there's a few
good ones but it's very difficult
it's not easy to take a good ufo picture
sorry like i remember even
i live in rochester new york not far
from the rochester airport
i remember being at a park right by the
airport
knowing that the airplanes come in every
so often i had a camera a digital camera
and i thought only shot take picture
of the aircraft coming in as it land
and i screwed up every single time i
mean it's not that it's impossible to do
but it's
it's not as easy i think as we think and
plus digital photography is still not
all that great honestly with an object
distant in the sky
how good is it going to be really you
need
commercial grade equipment for a lot of
these things
to get them
the way you want
i i you know i don't want to make
excuses for why are there not any great
photographs
the ones that are really that look great
initially often turn out to be hoaxes
that's true
a lot of them have but i don't think
they're all hoaxes i don't i just don't
believe that what about bodies
are there pictures of bodies that or of
the ufo or the alien exist living that
you find legitimate
uh none that i would i would bet the
mortgage on no
but what i will say is i'm a very big
fan and follower of the research of the
late leonard stringfield
i never got to meet lynch stringfield he
died in i think it was 94.
and he lived near us air force
headquarters near dayton ohio
not far from there i think he's in
cincinnati
and he was an ex-military guy himself
had seen a foo fighter during world war
ii over the pacific
and became a ufo researcher but in the
late 70s stringfield started
getting reports of
either crash ufos or alien bodies
story after story after story he started
like looking for them and and they came
to an all these different circuitous
routes and um
he collected them and he
you could drop 80 bucks on amazon if you
want right now and pick up stringfield's
400 page eight and a half by 11
collection of his
of all this research on that it's worth
it's actually fascinating it's
fascinating
um
but what he did is he collected
accounts from
military witnesses about you know one
guy will say well i did a security
detail at wright pat in 1960 whenever
and i saw
nine alien bodies
three to four feet tall with big big
heads you know that type of thing lying
on slabs or
variations of those types of stories
quite a few
and it's fascinating and i just think
it's a little too much smoke
for there not to be fire
i mean if i'm judging it by the
standards of rigorous science it has to
i have to say it flunks
fails
i mean can't get access to the body it's
true
i can't prove it
but
is that actually the ultimate criterion
i want to use or maybe i want to use one
of a counterintelligence officer instead
an investigator
sometimes you don't always have access
to the information what if it actually
is classified what if there is a black
budget world that manages this
information really really well which i
think is the case
in which
open and above board science is just not
going to have an opportunity to study
this stuff
what if that's the case
i think it is
so then you have to use other means of
ferreting out the information to the
best of your imperfect abilities
that's our world
you're extremely collected
moderated eloquent thank you man
i was a pleasure thank you kurt and
thanks to your listeners like they
people ask really good questions there's
over a thousand people watching
fabulous
wow
great well hi everybody thanks thanks
for hanging out
yes thank you and i'll email you
a couple
questions as well as with a link to the
final once it finally comes out
yeah fabulous i'll be very happy about
that thank you very much it was a
pleasure
man take care
thank you very much bye everybody
okay
thank you everyone
i appreciate you watching
if you have any
questions for me or suggestions or
comments i'll be sticking around for
approximately
two and a half minutes
reading through these
thank you thank you for people who are
giving me thanks
it's great to it's great to see someone
from south korea watching
i didn't get a chance to get to
everyone's questions it's actually
difficult to be in the moment with
the guest so in this case richard as
well as to
to read the chat i don't like to do so
and then often
oh richard is still in the waiting room
okay i'm gonna go because perhaps
richard would like to talk to me
take care
you